Hallo, da sind sie ja. Herzlich willkommen in unserem Atelier für elektronische Musik. Kommen sie bitte ein bisschen näher. Wir wollen ihnen was vorzaubern. Elektronik, Klänge, Musiken, Effekte, Krimieffekte und so weiter. Alles hier in diesen Geräten, die sie hier um sich sehen. Hier haben wir unsere Module, unsere Oszillatoren, alles mit Hebeln und Knöpfen. Keine Musiker, kein Dirigent. Wir zaubern das alles heute elektronisch.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 149. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute geht es mal wieder um Technik und außerdem geht es auch noch um Musik. Musik war ja hier in der letzten Zeit schon häufiger ein Thema und das macht auch so langsam den Eindruck, als könnte sich das hier als wiederkehrendes Meme auch einspielen. Denn umso genauer man dahinschaut, umso mehr merkt man, wie viel da so kulturell und technisch auch zu holen ist. Wir hatten hier Chaosradio 136, die Abhandlung über Techno mit Tarnit und Chaosradio Express 145, die sich mehr mit, wie soll man sagen, interaktiver digitaler Musik beschäftigt hat bzw. generell auf diesem kreativen Prozess. Und heute wiederum soll es um was ganz einfaches, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, gehen, wie das so ist. Die Basis ist einfach, die Ergebnisse sind komplex. Kurz gesagt, es geht um Synthesizer und um darüber ausführlich Auskunft zu geben, begrüße ich Andreas Schneider. Hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express.
Vielen Dank.
So viel Zeug wie du hat bisher noch keiner mitgebracht.
Na, das ist ja ein Ding, wobei der Platz ist hier ja reichlich vorhanden. Ich bin vorleitet. So richtig viel ist das auch nicht, das ist schon das kleine Besteck.
Also für so einen kleinen Podcast ist das auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz mächtig. Das ist jetzt auch der erste Podcast, wo ich mich echt gezwungen fühle, mit der Veröffentlichung auch ein Foto noch zu veröffentlichen, wonach häufig immer gefragt wird, damit ich mal sehr zurückhalte. Aber diesmal ist angemessen. Ja, ich blicke jetzt sozusagen, also es ist auch das erste Mal, dass mein Gegenüber mehr Technik-Gramm vor der Nase hat als ich.
Wobei, das würde ich bezweifeln, wenn ich genau hingucke rein mengenmäßig. Ich bin mit zwei Kleinen und einem großen Koffer dabei. Die trage ich alleine weg. Solltest du in die Verlegenheit kommen, mit deinem Studio von dann laufen zu müssen.
Das stimmt.
Da bist du schon auch ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Das stimmt schon. Ich hätte mehr zu schleppen, aber du hast mehr Module. Die sind bloß ein bisschen kleiner.
Genau. Also ich habe schon einige Sachen sehr kompakt mitgebracht.
Kurz gesagt, da vorne sind ein paar kleinere Geräte und zwei große Koffer fassen dann nochmal eine ganze Batterie von Modulen. Sprich, wir sind hier auch jetzt nicht nur bereit und in der Lage und vorbereitet, über das ganze Thema zu reden, sondern wir wollen hier auch ein bisschen Hands-On machen und auch mal hören, wie das alles so klingt. Synthesizer, das ist unser Thema und warum habe ich dich eingeladen? Dich habe ich eingeladen, weil du einen Laden hast, der passenderweise Schneiders Laden heißt. Da gehört auch noch ein Büro dazu. Also das Büro und Laden ist sozusagen dasselbe, oder?
Wir haben vor elf Jahren angefangen, Synthesizer für Kleinsthersteller in den Handel zu bringen oder an Fachmagazine zu kommunizieren, die derzeit keinen interessiert hat. Vor 15 Jahren gab es noch das Phänomen, dass man Minimooks für ein Apple und ein i kaufen konnte, weil die keiner mehr haben wollte. Da gab es eine Firma in den amerikanischen Ländern, die da die Tastatur abgesicht hat, ein MIDI-Interface rangebaut hat, ihre eigene Frontplatte davor geklebt hat und das MIDI-Mook genannt hat und die ist heute noch im Geschäft. Und derer gibt es ganz viele, die die analoge Klangwelt von Synthesizern, die vor 30, 40 Jahren durch große Hersteller gebaut worden sind, wiederentdeckt haben, als ihren Nabel, um so etwas wie Industrie zu werden. Und so kleinteilig dastehen, dass sie von den großen Vertriebskonzepten und noch nicht mal vom Fachhandel in jeder mittelgroßen Stadt erfasst werden können. Also ein Fachhändler in Rendsburg oder Bremen ist nicht in der Lage, einen Synthesizer anzubieten, der analog ist. Wenn man da reingeht, dann kriegt man die Informationen. Ja, super, hier gibt es von Kork, Yamaha, Roland, ABC. Und das ist im Prinzip das, was heutzutage eher als Konsumerelektronik aus meiner Sicht zu klassifizieren ist. Und das habe ich mir auf die Fahnen geschrieben, diesen Kleinstherstellern, die den Weg nicht gehen, sondern im Gegenteil dazu real analoge Klangerzeugung manchmal im Hinterhof in Kleinstauflage herzustellen, denenjenigen dann einen Weg zu ebnen, um ihre Sachen etwas besser verfügbar zu machen.
Das heißt, so einen Laden wie deinen gibt es eigentlich gar nicht viele von.
Ich bin der Einzige in Europa, würde ich mal sagen, der ausschließlich analoge Klangerzeugung macht, die heutzutage ausschließlich von Kleinstherstellern kommt.
Und außerhalb von Europa?
Außerhalb von Europa gibt es in Amerika inzwischen einen Kollegen, der da sehr kompetent bei der Sache ist, sogar drei. Und die hauen sich da gegenseitig auf die Mütze, wie das bei den Amis so üblich ist. Da wird die freie Marktwirtschaft ja etwas größer geschrieben. Und ich mache das dafür ein bisschen kollegialer und versuche eben nach wie vor den Einzelhandel, der vorhanden ist, einzubinden und verkaufe auch an sogenannte Fachgeschäfte in Fischbach oder Bruegebrach oder Frankfurt, wo sie alle sind, über Europa und versuche dann eben deren Kompetenz in ihren Landessprachen und in ihren einzubinden.
Ja, ich war ja neulich mal da. Man kommt da so rein, zwei große Räume im Wesentlichen als Ausstellungsbereiche mit allerlei Klaviatur und Gerät und dann insbesondere dieser eine Raum, wo die ganzen Modularen Synthesizer stehen, das ist schon sehr speziell. Da stehen dann auch ganz viele Leute rum und drehen ganz fleißig am Gerät und ernähren sich offensichtlich von Zischlauten und ähnlicher Klangerzeugung. Was sind denn das für Leute, die da so auftauchen?
Das trennt sich in diejenigen, die Musik machen und diejenigen, die Musik machen. Die einen sind die, die damit ihr Geld verdienen und die anderen sind die, die das immer machen wollten und die das als Passion sehen und teilweise da ein Hobby haben, was sie sich womöglich früher nicht leisten konnten und jetzt irgendwie den anderen. Ja, genau, also da ist schon mal ein Anwalt dabei, der in der bekannten Kanzlei arbeitet oder einer, der ein gutes, gutgehendes Restaurant hat und der nach Feierabend nochmal mit einem Glas Wein in sein Studio geht und nochmal einfach gerne jammen will, also Musik machen und nachts um zwei gibt's keine verlässliche Band und dann kann ich natürlich meinen Rechner hochfahren, aber wenn ich den ganzen Tag als Anwalt schon davor gesessen habe, habe ich auch keinen Bock mit meinem Rechner zu jammen und das ist auch, dann fange ich an doch nochmal nach, also ich mein, ein Instrument vor sich zu haben ist schon grandios. Das weiß jeder, der ein Instrument gelernt hat und dann noch eine Interaktion mit jemandem zu haben, der Mitmusiker ist, ist noch besser und wenn das aber beides zu der individuellen Stunde, zu der man es gerade haben will, nicht verfügbar ist, dann ist die haptisch erfahrbare Elektronik durchaus ein guter Ersatz, mit dem man sehr viel Vergnügen haben kann, woran man auch viel lernen kann und genau das wollte ich hier gleich ein bisschen erklären.
Genau, darum geht es ja hier auch immer, viel lernen. Das heißt Hobbyisten, aber auch Musiker, das heißt Leute, die jetzt Sound machen. Was zieht die denn zu diesen analogen Synthesizern? Man sagt ja schon, es hatte seine große Zeit, so 70er, 80er Jahre. Da war das dann irgendwie hittig. Dann kam so ein bisschen die Digitartechnik und so Universalgeräte, die alles Mögliche machen. Jedes Sequencer-Musikprogramm heutzutage auf dem Rechner kommt mit unzähligen Plug-Ins und da sind die Synthesizer alle mit drin. Was führt einen denn dann wieder zurück zu dem reinen Stahlmonster?
Die vermeintliche Qualität des Klanges, von der ich auch nach wie vor glaube, dass sie besser ist, bei Analoga Hardware. Das kann ja jeder gleich selber mal hören. Und die Einfachheit der haptischen Anwendung. Das heißt, wenn ich hier eine kleine Kiste habe, wo ich 16 Knöpfe drauf und zwölf Schalter habe und da stecke ich ein Kabel rein, die ist nicht mal so groß wie drei Schachteln Zigaretten. Und damit allein kann ich schon klanglich was herstellen, wo ich sonst irgendwie... Ja, klar kann ich das auch mit dem Computer machen. Ich kann alles mit dem Computer machen. Ich kann aber... Es ist einfach haptisch was anderes. Und ich stecke es rein und das geht los. Das funktioniert. Das macht, glaube ich, schon einen großen Unterschied aus. Ob das dann große Knöpfe hat, wo ich vernünftig zwischengreifen kann oder kleine Taster und ein bisschen bangt, das ist eine sekundäre Sache. Aber erst mal, wo ich überhaupt was anfassen kann und drauf spielen kann, ich glaube, das ist ganz wichtig.
Also Qualität und Interface. Das ist schon mal das Wichtigste.
Und der Klang auch.
Der Klang? Ja, also meine ich ja mit Qualität.
Ach so, Entschuldigung. Aber auch die Individualität. Das ist, glaube ich, auch wichtig, dass das in der Kombination von verschiedenen Hardware-Geräten, wie man sagt, natürlich, dass ich da ganz schnell bei einer Individualität bin. Das gibt es kein zweites Mal. Also das Setup, was hier auf dem Tisch steht, das gibt es mit Sicherheit kein zweites Mal. Diese Kombination von Modulen mit dieser Kombination von einer Rhythmusmaschine, einem kleinen Sequencer und einem kleinen Standalone-Synthesizer, so wie ich sie zusammenstecke, das passiert nur heute.
Ja.
Und das macht es, glaube ich, aus, weil es geht ja auch darum, dass man seine individuelle Marke setzt, dass man Musik macht, die es so vorher noch nicht gegeben hat, dass man auch mit Klängen experimentieren kann, wo vielleicht aus einem Rauschen und aus einem Störgeräusch etwas entsteht, was einen begeistert und was vielleicht sogar auch andere begeistert.
Das heißt, die Leute, die mit diesen Geräten arbeiten, sind vor allem Leute, die so explorativ ein bisschen auf der Suche nach dem neuen Klang sind?
Ganz genau.
Sind da noch nicht alle Klänge schon gespielt worden?
Noch lange nicht. Und das wird auch immer so weitergehen. Und ich würde da auch noch unterscheiden zwischen den Leuten, die dann noch einen Schritt weitergehen und sagen, okay, das Gerät A schraube ich vielleicht einfach mal auf und gucke mal, was da drin ist. Und oh, da sind ja irgendwie kleine Bauteile drin. Was passiert, wenn ich da ein Kabel ranlöte? Da gibt es auch einen etablierten Begriff, der heißt Circuit Bending. Da kaufen wir einfach irgendwelche crappy alten Drum-Maschinen für 20 Euro auf Ebay, schraubt die auf und gucke mal, was passiert, wenn ich da was ranlöte.
Weil dann meistens auch was passiert?
Ja, manchmal passiert halt einfach nichts mehr und manchmal ist das Ding kaputt, dann nehme ich halt die nächste und manchmal macht das Ding plötzlich... Und das ist vielleicht gut oder im besten Fall macht es... Weiß ich auch nicht, das ist nicht meine Welt.
Nicht schlecht, aber das war jetzt erstmal alles.
Mir ist gerade noch das Faxgerät angefangen, was da drin war, das in dem Jingle, der die Sendung eröffnet hat, der ja auch eigentlich schon wieder ein veralteter Laut ist, dieses Modemgeräusch. Das hast du aber echt gut drauf, man. Das dachte ich wollte ich noch mal zitieren. Aber ja, löten und einfach zusammenstecken und dazwischen ist die Grenze fließend. Also die Module, ich habe hier zwei Koffer mit Modulen zusammen, zusammengebaut und mitgebracht, wo ich eine wilde Kombination von unterschiedlichsten Herstellern miteinander verknüpfen kann. Da komme ich gleich drauf zu sprechen. Module sind ja auch was, wo ich zwar nicht drin löte, aber wo ich dann zumindest den VCA von der einen Firma mit der Höhlekurve von der anderen Firma mit dem Oszillator von der dritten Firma kombinieren kann. Und dadurch schon einen individuellen Synthesizer, den ich mir zusammengebaut habe, den es so nicht gibt. Und das ist, glaube ich, das Alleinstellungsmerkmal dessen, weswegen da so viele Leute drauf abfahren. Obendrein kommt dazu, dass das schon seit geraumer Zeit zunächst die ganze Techno-Elite, wenn man das so nennen kann, und dann aber auch viele Leute aus der Pop-Musik für sich entdeckt haben, weil das klanglich an den Orten, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt, dass die Bass-Drum aufrumst, nämlich am Dancefloor, dass sie festgestellt haben, dass man damit einfach schneller ans Ziel kommt. Wenn ich lerne, wie ich bei meinem Instrument die drei Knöpfe so hindrehe, dass die Bass-Drum einfach mal einen richtigen Bums macht, den ich gerne haben will, in Abgrenzung zu der Alternative, dass ich meine Presets durchgucke und ich habe womöglich eine Bass-Drum im Kopf und suche dann meine 50 verschiedenen Bass-Drum-Sounds durch, um die zu finden, die ich im Kopf hatte und höre dann 49 andere und habe die eigentliche, die ich im Kopf hatte, schon wieder vergessen. Klar, passiert mir das auch, wenn ich die selber formen muss, indem ich drei Kabel zusammenstecke und dann da dran drehe, aber beim fünften Mal habe ich gelernt, wie man die Bass-Drum so hindreht, wie ich es im Kopf habe und beim sechsten Mal wache ich auf und weiß, das muss ich ausprobieren, so könnte es gehen und drehe da dran und habe sie.
Das heißt auch dieser scheinbare Nachteil eines rein analogen Gerätes, was keinerlei digitale Speicherung hat, keine Presets, etc. ist am Ende vielleicht noch nicht mal ein Nachteil.
Nee, das kann sehr zum Vorteil sein. Kommt darauf an, wie ich arbeite. Wenn ich natürlich bei 3nacht9 der Unterhaltungskünstler bin, der irgendwie jeden Abend den gleichen Sound liefern muss und dann in einer Viertelstunde den anderen Sound, der wieder so ist wie der andere Sound gestern, dann bin ich damit schlecht beraten, dass ich dann die Knöpfe alle drehe. Gut, kann ich auch üben, aber dann muss ich halt üben. Letztendlich ist es immer die Frage, will ich auf einem Instrument üben oder will ich einfach nur was wiedergeben?
Man macht immer auf jeden Fall an dem Punkt weiter, wo man aufgehört hat, dass das auch was sehr Interessantes ist.
Ja, das stimmt, dass man nicht wegspeichert und woanders wieder drauf einlässt, dass man nicht hin und her springen kann.
Also kein Schreibtisch, den man immer wieder abgeräumt bekommt und so. Man kann auch wieder mit dem Zettel weiterschreiben, wo man zuletzt den Kugelschreiber draufgesetzt hat.
Aber da muss ich noch einen anderen Kontra-Aspekt. Es gibt ja auch noch die Frage, ob ich musiziere oder sammle. Da sind auch die Grenzen fließend. Viele Leute kommen natürlich mit der Motivation, dass sie musizieren wollen, zu der Materie, stellen fest, dass das Instrument der Tischgeräte oder analogen Komponenten die Mischung daraus ein tolles Instrument sein kann und suchen nach ihrem Instrument, nach ihrer Konstellation. Und suchen und probieren noch dies und probieren noch das und mutieren so nach und nach zum Sammler, weil sie sich kein Limit setzen. Man kann natürlich unendlich viele Sachen da anschaffen und die alten Sachen aus Opas Keller auch noch hochholen und dann da ranstecken und das funktioniert alles irgendwie zusammen. Und irgendwann hast du die Bude voll und hast immer noch keine Platte gemacht. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen der Modelleisenbahneffekt, den ich natürlich als Händler sehr begrüße, aber der demjenigen, der Musik machen will, nicht unbedingt weiterhilft. Glücklicherweise ist der Umstand, dass das meist sehr begrenzte Teile sind, dann da wieder sehr begünstigend, weil die Preise kaum verfallen, beziehungsweise manchmal sogar einfach hochgehen. Also es gibt Sachen, die verkaufen wir und die finden wir dann ein Jahr später oder zwei Jahre später für zumindest den anderthalbfachen Preis auf eBay wieder, wo ich denke, aha, okay, naja, gut.
Also die Dinger haben Wert. Auf jeden Fall.
Es ist halt gelöteter Hardware, es ist Handarbeit und wir versuchen, unser möglichstes Wertschätzung gegenüber dem Kleinsthersteller zu erhalten und zu fördern. Also nicht künstlich jetzt irgendwie. Wir wollen einfach nur das zur Verfügung stellen und der Kunde ist unser Kunde, aber wir gehen auch nicht nach der Maßkabel vor, dass ein Kleinsthersteller jedes halbe Jahr ein neues Produkt haben muss oder einmal im Jahr, um zur Messe wieder mit dem neuen und jetzt da noch ein Knopf mehr und jetzt hier noch eine Buchse extra. Die Welt muss nicht neu erfunden werden, sondern das ist eigentlich eher andersrum. Viele der Produkte, die wir haben, sind einfach gut und sollten auch durchaus gerne über Jahrzehnte verkaufen. Warum denn verändern, wenn es funktioniert? Es ist einfach eine stehende Größe.
Es geht ja auch gar nicht so sehr ums Meer, sondern es geht eigentlich nur darum, eine interessante Mischung zu finden von Einflussnahmemöglichkeiten. Und das setzt natürlich bei dem Hersteller ein großes Verständnis raus. Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass da aber auch eine ganze Menge Leute, die so sehr ingenieurhaft sind, teilweise am Wirken sind. Wie groß ist denn dann der Querschnitt von Leuten, die Geräte bauen und die auch Musik machen zum Beispiel? Sind das so Leute, die beides tun, oder ist das wirklich so, da gibt es so die Leute, die bauen lieber und dann gibt es Leute, die nutzen lieber, was da gebaut wird?
Das eine geht in das andere über. Es gibt den Musiker, der zum Ingenieur wird, weil ihm eine Komponente fehlt, die er für sich selber baut und dann feststellt, das brauchen auch andere. Davon baue ich jetzt mal ein paar mehr. Und es gibt den Ingenieur, der da rangeht und der irgendwann feststellt, Mensch, da gibt es einen Bedarf. Das kann ich ja viel besser als der Typ, der das da eigentlich sich ausgedacht hat. Also die kreative Komponente und. Die andere Hälfte des Gehirns.
Welche auch immer jetzt die linke und die rechte ist.
Aber sie funktioniert am besten zusammen. Und der eine kommt von links nach rechts, der andere kommt von rechts nach links. Beide kommen zum Ergebnis und es macht natürlich keinen Sinn, wenn ich den tollsten Synthesizer der Welt von ihm am Entworfen habe, wenn ich ihn am Ende nicht kriege, weil er nicht funktioniert. Also muss ich dann auch abwägen, dann kaufe ich lieber den, der nicht so viel Innovation hat, aber der funktioniert wenigstens immer gleich und damit bin ich glücklich. Und klasse, weil der hat einfach nochmal nachgerechnet und kann mir das Ding für 800 verkaufen und der andere fragt nach 2000. Aber weiß ich auch nicht, ob das jetzt für die Funktion so viel Mehrwert bringt, wenn ich gerade erst damit anfange.
Machen wir doch mal den obligatorischen Sprung in die Geschichte, weil so neu ist das alles nicht mehr, aber es gab definitiv auch mal eine Zeit ohne elektronische Klangerzeugung. Wann ging das so los? 70er?
In den 20er Jahren ging das los mit den ersten Entwicklungen, wo statt Telefon für Telefonübertragung dann Telefone für Konzerte verwendet wurden und wo Leute Lautsprecher installiert haben, die dann missbraucht wurden für die laute Abbildung von Rauschen und so was. Ergebnisse davon waren zum Beispiel auch so was wie das Mixtur-Trautonium und in Frankreich gab es das Eau de Martenot, in Deutschland gab es eben Oscar Sala und dann gab es noch den Lev Termin, der in den 20ern, glaube ich, schon mit seinem Termin eine Frau auf die Bühne gestellt hat, die dann an einer Antenne eine Frequenz verändern konnte und das hat er da als Zauberei promotet und hat damit wohl einen Haufen Geld gemacht. Ausgewertet hat diese Entwicklung dann eine Firma Moog aus den USA, die noch heute oder heute wieder für Synthesizer-Produkte bekannt ist und ein Herr Termin ist, glaube ich, relativ arm, das weiß ich aber nicht genau, in Russland dann irgendwann gestorben. Angeblich wollte der Geheimdienst seine Erfindung wieder haben und hat ihn dann wohl in den USA abgeholt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Anekdote ist.
Das Termin und das Trautonium.
Genau, das gibt es auch heute noch. Zum Beispiel, in dem habe ich auch hier mal Beispiele mitgebracht. Hier vor mir guckt eine Antenne aus meinem Modular-Koffer. Die sieht aus wie eine billige Radio-Antenne und da kann ich mich mit der Hand annähern. Und die Tonhöhe eines Oszillators verändern. Ich drehe mal hier ein bisschen auf, dann haben wir mal hier einen ersten Klang. Das, was wir dann tuckern hören, ist ein Oszillator. Der macht immer eine gleichbleibende Frequenz, ist aber spannungsstörbar. Das erkläre ich gleich noch ein bisschen mehr im Detail. Und wenn ich mich mit meiner Hand der Antenne nähere, dann verändert sich die Frequenz von dem Oszillator. Und je näher ich rangehe, dann geht es so weit. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel die Lautstärke noch steuere und das ein bisschen übe, dann kann ich... Da muss ich halt sehr viel üben, weil das auch eine eher kleine Antenne ist, mit der ich zum Beispiel einen Filter steuern kann oder... Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger, jetzt in diesem Ambienten richtig tonal eine Melodie hinzukriegen. Da eignet sich dann doch eher ein richtiges Termin, was man auch heutzutage noch kaufen kann, wo man eine Antenne für die Lautstärke und eine Antenne für die Tonhöhe hat. Und dann davor steht und richtig Melodien spielt.
Ich blicke hier gerade auf die aufgezeichnete Audiokurve in meinem Programm und muss sagen, das sieht schon außergewöhnlich interessant aus. Also man kann wirklich so deine Handbewegung wirklich auch direkt so aus der Welle rauslesen. Das ist mal echt schick hier. Ja, natürlich. Natürlich, natürlich. Aber da muss man ja auch erst mal sehen. Jetzt müsst ihr euch die Audiodatei noch mal auf dem Computer mit dem Audioprogramm aufmachen. Allerdings sollte man nicht so viel davon reden. So, das heißt, 20er Jahre, da ging das irgendwie los. Auch so mit dem Radio. Also Strom und Audio wurde irgendwie verbunden.
Ja, ganz genau. Dann passierte zum Beispiel der Oskar Sala, hat dann sein Mixtur-Trautonium entwickelt, was er hat bauen lassen. Das ist ein Gleitmanual gewesen, wo in Quecksilberbädern so ein Stück Metall eingetunkt hat und damit irgendwas verändert hat, was dann den Oszillator in seiner Tonhöhe beeinflusst hat. Je nachdem, wie doll er auf so ein Metallband gedrückt hat, hat sich die Eintauchtiefe des am Ende dieses Bandes hängenden irgendwas verändert und hat dann da einen Widerstandswert verändert. Oder ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich bin halt kein Techniker, ich bin der armselige Kaufmann. Und über die Position, wo man dieses Band angefasst hat, konnte man die Tonhöhe verändern. Das steht heute noch in verschiedenen Museen, gibt es verschiedene Versuche, ihm ein adäquates Instrument zu bauen. Da haben sich dann irgendwann Telefunkentechniker aufgeschwungen, ihm ein neues Transistor-betriebenes Mixtur-Trautonium zu bauen, was er aber nie so richtig benutzt hat. Er fand immer dieses Röhrenmonster, was er hatte, viel besser. Und das war sein Standard. Das steht, glaube ich, in München im Museum, hier in Berlin im Musikinstrumentmuseum steht dieses Siemens Transistorelement sehr armselig irgendwo etwas vergessen in der Ecke. Und man kann auch heutzutage ein Replika, womit man ähnliche Klänge generieren kann, aus dem Modularsystem kaufen, wo sich dann eben auch einer der Hersteller aus München engagiert hat, das als Modulbaukasten nachzubauen.
So richtig mit Quicksilber eintauchen und so?
Nee, das hat so nicht stattgefunden, das war zu kompliziert und das ist ja auch eh gefährlich und verboten. Aber der hat sich dann mit einem Wandmanual, mit einem Ribbon-Controller, einen Positionssensor, das ist ein Streifen, den kann ich mir auf die Lederjacke kleben, und der verändert den Widerstand, wenn ich mit meinem Finger ganz oben oder ganz unten da drauf gehe. Ich habe so etwas mal mitgebracht. So, jetzt habe ich hier so einen 50 cm Streifen, da kann ich von ganz unten, ich stelle den mal ein bisschen tiefer, so bis ganz nach oben hoch gehen und wieder runter und der verändert dann die Tonhöhe. Ich kann die Skalierung noch verstellen, dann habe ich einen weiteren Bereich und kann jetzt natürlich, und durch das Anfassen dieses Sensors, darunter ist ein Drucksensor und schon durch das Anfassen des Sensors gibt ein Modul, an dem der hängt, eine Steuerspannung raus, die einen VCA auf und zu macht und dadurch geht der Ton an oder aus. Aber da sind wir ja schon mitten in dem Thema, wo wir eigentlich hinwollten, nämlich die klassischen Komponenten von einem Synthesizer grundsätzlich mal zu erklären.
Soll ich ihn einfach fortfahren? Vielleicht noch mal kurz den geschichtlichen Pfad verlassen, dass wir zumindest einen kleinen Überblick da kriegen. Also wir hatten jetzt so Teremin, Trautonium, das waren so Oscar Sala, der hat ja auch mit an diesem Trautonium mit entwickelt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Erfinder ist eigentlich Friedrich Trautwein.
Trautwein war, glaube ich, ein Komponist und Oscar Sala hat sich das ausgedacht und hat die Entwicklung dessen vorangetrieben. Aber da habe ich auch ein professionelles Verkäufer-Halbwesen.
Ja, die Wikipedia meinte, wären da so beide dabei gewesen. Und vor allem heißt es halt Trautonium, weil es halt Herr Trautwein ist. Das ist ja auch sehr naheliegend.
Ja, kann auch sein. Ach so, okay, gut, kann auch sein. Auf jeden Fall hat Sala Karriere damit gemacht, dass er das angewendet hat. Fällt mir dabei auch ein.
Genau, er ist der Erste, der das auch gespielt hat bis vor wenigen Jahren. 2002 ist er dann gestorben.
Er hatte das einzige oder die einzigen funktionierenden Exemplare von diesem Instrument und hat damit diverse Filmmusiken eingespielt und hat die industrielle Herstellung des Instrumentes, glaube ich, auch immer so ein bisschen flach gehalten, weil so lange er nur eher eins hat, kann er auch nur eher damit Filmmusiken machen. Und er hat damit halt einfach sein Lebensunterhalt bestritten und im besten Fall zum Beispiel die gesamte Musik von Hitchcock's Vögel erstellt auf dem Mixtur Trautonium, wo dann eben zu diesem Geräusch, was wir eben hören, was jetzt nicht besonders sexy war, dann noch ein Hall war und dann noch ein Filter dahinter, wo das dann tatsächlich so ein weinerliches Musikstück werden kann und man da sehr viel spannende Sachen mitmachen kann.
Das ist auch so mein Eindruck gewesen, dass eigentlich es die Filmmusiken waren, wo eigentlich dieser elektronische Klang das erste Mal sich wirklich manifestiert hat. Während das so in der klassischen Musik damals so ja nicht, also klar, Oskar Sala saß da wahrscheinlich mit seinem Trautonium und dann hat man sich den wahnsinnigen Offerbindung angeschaut und dann so, das war eher interessant, aber jetzt gehen wir mal wieder zurück zu unserem Cello und Nefah und unserer Geige. Aber dass das jetzt wirklich so als Musikinstrument in der populären oder, wenn auch nur experimentellen Musik, wirklich eine große Verbreitung gefunden hat in der Zeit, kann man nicht sagen, oder?
Doch, da würde ich gerne das dritte Beispiel aus gleicher Zeit anfügen, das Entmartenot, was in Frankreich entwickelt wurde, was eine Tastatur hat, wo parallel zur Tastatur an einem Fingerring ein Draht geführt werden kann, der dann auch einen gleitenden Ton generiert. Und das Entmartenot wurde ausnotiert, auch für viele klassische Kompositionen in Frankreich, und wird heute noch nachgefragt, wer ein Entmartenot hat, was funktioniert. Der ist ein gefragter Mann in der klassischen Musik und kriegt schon dafür, dass er das Entmartenot zu den Aufführungsstätten trägt, ein gewisses Honorar. Und wenn er es dann noch spielen kann, dann hat er erst recht gewonnen. Da gibt es wohl inzwischen wieder eine Firma in der Nähe von Paris, die vergleichbare Instrumente herstellt. Und das ist auch ein niemals nachempfundenes Original in seiner Klangformung. Ähnlich dem Mixtur Trautonium mit einem integrierten Hall und verschiedenen Diskanten, also die Benennung der Klangformung da. Ich habe neulich bei einem Film Musikkomponisten von Die wunderbare Welt der Amélie. Der war auf Tournee oder nee, der war nicht hier auf Tournee, aber der hat hier geübt für seine Tournee. Und der hat eine Spielerin auf dem Ensemble No replica dabei gehabt. Und die hatte sich bei mir ein Hallgerät gekauft.
Und hier ist er?
Genau.
Das ist der, der die tolle Musik gemacht hat.
Genau. Und der benutzt auch heute, bedient sich glücklicherweise einer Spielerin des Honds Martenot in aktueller Musik, die sehr stimmungsvoll ist. Hond mit H oder mit Hond? Hondes Martenot. Das Instrument. Martenot. Das sind dann die deutschen Sagen.
Ich find nichts.
Z hat mein H davor, ein Heinrich.
Hab ich.
Nee, dann nimm das H wieder weg. Finden wir noch.
Wir finden das noch.
Aber das war das dritte.
Onde.
Onde Martenot.
O N D E S.
Onde.
Onde. Onde.
Onde Martenot.
Jetzt haben wir's.
Die Martenowellen sozusagen. Ah ja, auch sehr hübsch. Auch so schön in Holz und so.
Ja, durchaus. Da spielt die Ästhetik natürlich auch wieder eine Rolle. Und die Assoziation zu einem Instrument aus der Klassik, was nun Klavier, Czembalo oder Geige oder irgendwas sein könnte, was dann aus einem eben Metall gefertigt ist. Nicht aus Metall gefertigt ist, sondern eben Holz hat, ist da auch, glaube ich, wichtig.
Angeregt durch ein Treffen mit dem Erfinder des Therémin. So, so.
Na ja, okay. Da haben wir wieder den Querverweis.
Der Schwebungssummer. Wie das Therémin beruht auch und immer nur auf dem Prinzip des Schwebungssummers.
Was den heutzutage durch, also in der Popularmusik ja durch den Oszillator ersetzt ist.
Beat frequency oscillator. Guck an. So, das waren also sozusagen frühe Musikgeräte und man hat sich dann auch eigentlich gleich bemüht, quasi aus dem theoretischen Klang, den man da erzeugen kann, auch gleich so ein fertiges Instrument zu bauen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz interessant, dass eigentlich alle drei gleich irgendwie dann so wirklich was Fertiges zum Hinstellen mit einer manuellen Bedienung bauen. Und jetzt könnte man ja auch sagen, so gerade damals in der experimentellen Zeit, wo eh alles nur im Wesentlichen nackte Kabel waren, hätte man ja auch gleich mit so analogen Synthesizer-Technologien da herkommen können. Aber soweit war da wahrscheinlich die Denke noch gar nicht. Aber dann, gut, das heißt, dann gab es halt Leute, die dieses Musikinstrument gespielt haben, als solches. Aber das waren dann aber auch alles immer noch so kleine Einzelgänger.
Ja, aber das ist heute auch noch. Im Vergleich dazu, wie viele Leute heutzutage Musik machen und Musik konsumieren, sind diejenigen, die diese Sachen, die hier vor mir stehen, anwenden, immer noch Einzelgänger.
Ja gut, aber die Klangwelt, die hat ja nun wirklich massiv Einzug gehalten in unsere Gesellschaft.
Ja, weil wir überall Geräusche haben. Aber ich glaube, das ist damals auch nicht anders gewesen, bloß dass wir nicht so viel davon aufgenommen haben. Also ob nun ordentlich oder das Hupen anders gewesen ist oder die Motorengeräusche haben sich auch verändert und...
Ja gut, aber es ist ja schon ein Unterschied, ob so ein Gerät existiert und jemand in der Lage ist, da Musik zu machen, die dann ein paar Leute ganz gut finden oder ob das dann wirklich so kulturellen Einfluss hat, dass es auch wirklich größere Massen erfasst, was ja dann sozusagen mit der Filmmusik der Fall war. So Hitchcock, Vögel, gutes Beispiel, nicht wahr, da geht es auch so um dieses, man weiß nicht genau, Suspense und dramatische Situationen erfordern auch dramatische Musik und da hat es dann halt irgendwie auch geholfen, diese Klangwelten zu machen. Dann halt auch diese ganze Science-Fiction-Welle, gerade zu 50er-Jahre ging es dann los, dieses, alles was irgendwie so schwebte und nicht von dieser Welt war sozusagen. Im Prinzip ist das ja die Klangwelt, die eben nicht aus dem Holz kommt und nicht irgendwie von der geschlagenen Seite, sondern die aus irgendetwas entsteht, was man so irgendwie nicht nachvollziehen kann, weil es halt einfach Elektronen sind, die irgendwie dagegen fliegen. Aber irgendwann hat sich das ja dann auch konsolidiert und irgendwann ist dann auch auf die Idee gekommen, daraus dann wirklich Musikinstrumente zu bauen, die jetzt nicht nur so für sich stehen, sondern die eben auch parametrisierbar waren, wo es gerade darum ging, nicht nur einen Ton oder eine bestimmte Tonfamilie wiederzugeben, die jetzt dem Erfinder genügte, sondern das Gerät auch wirklich als Klangerzeugungsmaschine zu verstehen.
Nein, ich glaube, die Motivation war doch eher mal, die Naturinstrumente nachzuempfinden erstmal, um die rekonstruierbar zu machen. Also auch das Klavier ist ja eine ziemliche Limitierung der tonalen Vielfalt, wenn ich da nur zwölf Töne drauf habe, obwohl ich die Seite ja irgendwie verstimmen und verspannen kann in alle möglichen und auch auf dem Kontrabass lerne, wie man intoniert und wie man aber auch dazwischen intoniert und von hier nach da rutschen kann, dann ist das auf dem Klavier plötzlich weg und du hast nur noch zwölf Töne, bis du den einen wieder erreichst, der eine Oktave höher ist als der letzte. Und ich glaube, da waren die natürlich dann wieder freier. Also das Trautonium, das En-Martino und das Teremin sind ja chromatische Verläufe, wo ich keine 12-Ton-Skalierung habe. Da basiert dann eine elektronische Klangezeugung, die natürlich wieder freier ist in ihrer tonalen Realität. Und es folgte dann die Entwicklung von Synthesisern, die sich wieder am Klavier orientieren, weil das eingabe-mäßig eher unserem derzeitigen kulturellen Horizont entsprochen hat, schätze ich mal. Dass man dann wieder 12-Ton-Musik rekonstruierbar in Elektronik gemacht hat und das dann auch wieder zum Konsumeprodukt gemacht hat, was dann irgendwie Leute kaufen konnten. Das Modularsystem von Moog, das erste, was ein ziemlich großer Trümmer war, das war ja nun auch wieder frei, weil es ein Modularsystem war. Da gibt es sehr spannende Videos von einem gewissen Herrn Funk, der da in den 70er Jahren das Modularsystem von Moog importiert hat und auch präsentiert. Sehr amüsant, weil der ein Unterhalter vor dem Herrn war und vor laufender Kamera in seiner Zeit und ZDF dann die Kabel gesteckt hat und das so leichtfertig. Ja, dann stecken wir hier mal eben Kabel und gucken Sie, so leicht geht das, wenn Sie mal eine richtige Horrorfilmmusik wollen, dann stecken Sie einfach hier ein Kabel rein, da kommt eine Wellenform raus, dann stecken Sie das in den Filter und dann machen Sie hier noch was rein und zum Schluss wurde dann noch inszeniert, dass das ganze Studio in Rauch und Flammen aufgeht und Herr Funk hat sich den Kittel ausgezogen und ist nach Hause gegangen. Das war wirklich sehr amüsant und sehr empfehlenswert als modulare Workshop-Videos. Herr Funk ist inzwischen irgendwie, muss so um die 90 Jahre alt sein und gerade neulich wurde sein Modularsystem auf Ebay angeboten für einen horrenden Sammlerpreis von nur 35.000 Euro oder so. Was weiß ich nicht. Ist halt so. Das sind dann die Schätzchen von gestern, die die Wertschöpfung für die Schätzchen von heute in der Vision der Besitzer teilweise in skurrile Höhen wandern lässt.
So so. Heinz Funk also.
Heinz Funk, genau.
Ich habe hier sogar was gefunden. Das ist mich so heiß gemacht hier auf Herrn Funk.
Nehmen wir an, es braucht jemand als Untermalung für ein Hörspiel oder für einen Film einen Sturmwind. Keiner wird auf die Idee kommen, mit dem Sturmwind draußen zu gehen und mit dem Mikrofon einen Wind aufzunehmen. Das ist viel zu kompliziert. Es ist ja hier viel einfacher. Wir nehmen einen Rauschgenerator, führen ihn über einen Lowpass-Filter, heben den Resonanzpunkt ein bisschen an, damit er etwas heulen bekommt. Dann stecken wir die Sprechdauer-Spannung eines Rippen-Controllers auf den Kontrolleingang, den Filter. Ganz einfach. Und nun bewegen wir einfach den Fingerrauch und wir haben den schönsten Sturmwind.
Sturmwind.
Sturmwind kriegst du auch hier, sagst du? Ja, ich habe meinen Rauschen vergessen.
Soll ich noch mein Mikrofon anschließen?
Rauschen habe ich gerade nicht da, aber theoretisch hier. Ach so, hier habe ich Rauschen, siehst du.
Aber damit hat er es gerade gemacht, oder was? Er hat irgendwie Rauschen genommen.
Ja, genau. Nimm mal ein Rauschen. Hier haben wir ein bisschen Rauschen. Weißes Rauschen vielleicht. Dann nehmen wir mal einen Filter. Schicken wir das in so einen Filter rein hier.
Was unterscheidet das weiße Rauschen von anderem Rauschen?
Frag mich nicht. Das können wir aber jetzt experimentell ermitteln. Da haben wir einen Filter, Audio in, Audio.
Jetzt ist schon der erste Jogger mit Kopfhörer auf gegen Baum gelaufen, ist dir klar, ne?
Na ja, dafür weht sie jetzt mal ordentlich um die Nase. So und jetzt pur in seiner Reihenform. Das Rauschen, das war das weiße Rauschen. Und jetzt gehen wir mal auf das bunte Rauschen, wo ich dann noch drei Farben mischen kann hier.
Jetzt sollte man dazu sagen, wenn du da umwechselst auf eine andere Quelle, dann steckst du halt das Kabel in ein anderes Loch.
Genau.
Das ist sozusagen, das heißt eins deiner Module ist ein Rauschgenerator.
Genau, hier haben wir ein Modul, das heißt A118, da steht oben Noise und Random Voltage und da habe ich einen Ausgang, also eine Buchse, da stecke ich einen Kabel rein, was dann weiterführt zu unserem Lautsprecher in eine Buchse namens White. Die hören wir hier.
Schön.
Dann mache ich den Filter mal wieder ganz auf, dann hören wir alle Frequenzen von White. Und dann gehe ich da mal raus und gehe in die Colored Rauschen. Da gibt es zwei Regler daneben. Der eine heißt blau, der andere heißt rot. Rot scheint die tiefere Frequenz zu sein. Wenn ich beide zudrehe auf Null, dann ist das das, was übrig bleibt. Jetzt drehe ich nochmal blau auf. Das wieder zu. Drehe ich rot auf.
Jetzt haben wir so ein paar Wellen, wenn es dann wieder rein schlag.
Und jetzt drehe ich die mal beide auf. Und dann habe ich dieses Signal durch einen Filter gejagt. Das hat der liebe Herr Funk eben auch gemacht. Da habe ich eine Frequenz. Das ist ein Tiefpass-Filter. Da kann ich jetzt die Schnittfrequenz, wo die tiefen Frequenzen noch drunter liegen und durch können und die hohen Frequenzen abgeschnitten werden, mit einem Drehregler verändern. Bis zur Unkenntlichkeit, dass da nur so tiefe Frequenzen überbleiben, dass wir die kaum noch wahrnehmen. Vielleicht bummert es ein bisschen bei denen, die bessere Boxen haben.
Das ist auch die Frage, was da bei mir im Kopf ist. Das ist auch die Frage, was da bei mir im Kopf ist. Ich glaube, diese Sendung muss ich mal mit einer höheren Bitrate entkommen.
Ja, das könnte helfen.
Okay, ich denke als Ausflug in die Rauschwelten reicht das jetzt erst mal.
Okay, danke Herr Funk.
Wir wollen ja die Leute nicht überfordern. Jetzt muss ich erstmal ein bisschen wieder zurückspulen. Das heißt, synthetische Klangerzeugung war dann hier sozusagen auch schon von Anfang an so als Soundgenerator, ja eigentlich auch so im Wesentlichen für Film und Fernsehen dann auch wichtig.
Herr Funk hat selber gesagt und hat gesagt, da bin ich einfach viel schneller, das stecke ich da rein, da gehe ich doch nicht nach draußen und nehme das auf, sondern das reicht für die Klangwelt dessen, was der Hörer erwartet, weil er das sowieso nochmal assoziiert mit dem Bild und dann weiß, worum es geht. Und es geht ja um die Information über eine Situation und die Klangwiedergabe zuhause war ja nun auch nicht gerade so high fidelity, mit sogar für Übertragungen etc.,
dass es dann auch noch ein bisschen egal war. Aber heutzutage kann das ja schon wieder ganz anders sein, heute kommt es dann schon auf gute Qualität an, weil die gute Qualität sich dann halt doch wirklich bis zum letzten Kopfhörer erhalten kann, wenn man es drauf hat.
Aber das stimmt ja gar nicht. Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass die gute Qualität eher verloren geht in Zeiten, wo alle an der Haltestelle stehen und nicht mal mehr einen Ghetto-Blaster haben, der die Ausmaße einer Tiefkühltruhe hat, sondern nur noch ihr Handy in die Luft halten und damit Musik hören und sich nicht mal mehr einen Kopfhörer gönnen, sinkt das Niveau dessen, was Qualität in Klang sein soll, doch erheblich. Also mit der nächsten Generation werden viele klangliche Möglichkeiten dessen, die wir hatten, wahrscheinlich schon wieder verloren sein und irgendwann entdeckt das wieder jemand zurück. Also selbst dieses Modularsystem hier, mein klangliches Rauschen, was ich generiere mit den Modulen, entspricht natürlich nicht dem, was womöglich einen höheren Rauschgenerator vor 30 oder 50 oder 70 Jahren gemacht hat. Ob das eine besser ist als das andere, sei dahingestellt, aber auf jeden Fall ist es anders und ist dann die Frage, was ist das Original und was ist viel charmanter oder entspricht mehr dem, wo wir hin wollen. Es gibt ja auch viele digitale Klangwelten, die man analog oder irgendwie, die einfach neu sind, die interessant sind und die mit Sicherheit unsere Kultur des Hörens prägen werden und die man niemals analog rekonstruieren kann. Natürlich kann ich sie irgendwie samplen und dann wiedergeben, aber ich kann sie da nicht schöpfen, weil sie einfach digitale Klänge sind. Mit Moog ging es los und wurde es plötzlich zu einem Produkt. Weil Moog war auch Kaufmann oder wollte gerne einer sein. Und hat dann nicht nur ein Experimentier-Ding gebaut, womit er dann eine Filmmusik gemacht hat, sondern er hat gedacht, wie baue ich davon 20 Stück, 30 Stück und wie werde ich die los? Und hat Modularsysteme und später auch Synthesizer an Menschen wie die Stones oder die Stones haben es nicht verstanden und haben es zurückgeschickt, aber diverse Künstler der Pop, Elektronik und Unterhaltungsmusik verkauft und hat dann weltweit das neben anderen, die in gleicher Zeit auch mit der Materie gearbeitet haben, etabliert.
Was waren denn so, fallen dir ein paar wichtige Künstler ein, die jetzt auch den Synthesizer als solchen wirklich in den Mittelpunkt gestellt haben, die nicht nur einstehen hatten und dann hat er halt so den Beat gemacht und dann war es das, sondern die auch jetzt wirklich da explorativ so rangegangen sind oder sich vielleicht auch ihre eigenen Sachen gebaut haben?
Die hatten glaube ich alle einen Stehen der Zeit, aber die meisten haben daran ein bisschen rum experimentiert und sind nicht zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, was das Produkt hätte abbilden können oder haben es teilweise dann irgendwie auch nicht als das erkannt, was es hätte sein können. Ich weiß jetzt eher die Leute von heute, die das Zeug benutzen und zwischenzeitlich gab es so eine Phase Tangerine Dream definiert sich glaube ich eher schon durch sowas. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Da hast du glaube ich ja so Größen wie, was weiß ich, Jean-Michel Jarre.
Genau, das ist doch eine ganz dicke Nummer, die heute noch dabei ist und mit Sammlungen an analoge Hardware auf Tour geht und das ganze Zeug dabei hat.
Also auch nicht jeder meins Geschmack. Also mein Geschmack traf es schon, bei einem großen Jarre-Fan kann ich mich gleich mal mitrauten. Ich fand das bemerkenswert, wie der, ja auch ausschließlich, also es ist ja nicht so, dass es nur ein Gerät gewesen wäre und dann hat er dazu auf seine Gitarre geschrammelt oder so, sondern seine gesamte Musik war ja Synthesizer-Musik. Dann gab es auch noch diesen verrückten Japaner.
Pink Floyd hat doch auch ganz viel mit so einem Zeug gemacht. Ach so.
Pink Floyd Japaner.
Verrückte Japaner, ja.
Gut, aber Pink Floyd hat es für ihn gemischt, nicht wahr? Also das war ja keine reine Synthesizer-Melodie. Jetzt überlege ich gerade, wie hieß denn dieser verrückte Japaner, von dem ich dann auch mal irgendwie so eine CD hatte. Da komme ich vielleicht gleich noch drauf. Kraftwerk?
Ja, genau, Kraftwerk ist ja das Paradebeispiel.
Die haben aber auch wirklich selbst gebaut. Die haben ja auch selber experimentiert oder haben die sich bauen lassen?
Die haben sich bauen lassen.
Also die hatten sozusagen ihre eigene Community, in der solche Sachen da aufgestanden sind.
Ein ganz markantes Produkt war der EMS Synthie aus dem freundlichen England. Der auch wiederum ein Synthesizer war. Der wurde sowohl als Tisch-Synthesizer, als sogenanntes Desktop-Modell, als auch als Koffer ausgeliefert. Und hatte dann neben den Kabelverknüpfungen, die man da reinstecken kann, um interne Verbindungen zu unterbrechen und dann externe Informationen zuzuführen, hatte er eine Patch-Matrix, wo man so Steckverbinder reinstecken konnte, um dann Klänge zu generieren, die aus der Verknüpfung von diversen Komponenten in wilder Reihenfolge generiert werden konnten. Florian Schneider hatte einen Kraftwerk von Konrad Schnitzler, so weit ich weiß. Konrad Schnitzler war der Vorzeigeschlosser-Junge aus dem Schülerkreis des Professors Josef Beuys von der Kunstakademie Düsseldorf, der nur seine Professur in Düsseldorf angetreten hat, wenn da auch einfache Menschen Zugang zu haben. Ich glaube, Konrad Schnitzler war zu der Zeit ein einfacher Mensch und ist dann in die Musik gegangen und hat Synthi A oder Synthi AKS, heißt der von der Firma EMS.
Also ich bin hier...
Das ist das, was Tim hat gerade, ein schönes Bild recherchiert von einem Synthi A 100, war das, glaube ich. Nee, AB 2500. Ja gut, aber das sind dann so die größeren Schiffe. Und der Synthi A oder Synthi AKS war ein relativ kompaktes Modell. Und damit hat dieser Konrad Schnitzler zeitweise... Ja, davon gibt es eine Kofferversion, was du da jetzt auch gerufen hast.
Genau, da habe ich den mal eingefunden.
Genau.
Das ist diese kleine Matrix, das sieht so ein bisschen aus, wie Schiffe versenken.
Genau, so sieht das aus. Und wenn du da die richtigen Pins reinsteckst, dann macht das Ding plötzlich von selber Rock'n'Roll. Also nicht das, was wir als Rock'n'Roll aus der Geschichte kennen, sondern macht dann eben oder sowas und das über Stunden. Und dann hat sich zu der Performance eines solchen Instrumentes über die größten Boxen, die er kriegen konnte, zum Beispiel ein Herr Schnitzler mit dem Rücken zum Publikum in die Frankfurter Oder, Frankfurter Oper gestellt, mit einem Neonstreifen auf dem Rücken und hat das 60er Jahre Schlips und Kragen Publikum unserer Eltern- und Großelterngeneration mit dem empört, was heutzutage noch den Jugendlichen begeistert, wenn er das Rauschen aus meinem Modularsystem über einen Zufallsgenerator verbindet und sagt, das ist ja geil, das macht ja... Und dazu noch ein bisschen... und die Halle rockt. Das reicht ja. Das ist eigentlich für jeden grandios, wenn man dann drei Kabel steckt und denkt, Mensch, so was, das habe ich so noch nie gehört und das habe ich jetzt gemacht. Dann sage ich, ja, das hast du jetzt gemacht. Und dann... das hat aber Konrad Schnitzler vor 30 Jahren so ähnlich auch schon gemacht.
War alles schon mal da. Jetzt sollten wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr hier auch das Gerät an Start bringen, weil ich wollte mal so ein bisschen hier, also jetzt auch nicht so viel Zeit in ewigen Geschichtsrepetitionen verlieren, sondern mich würde jetzt wirklich mal so ein bisschen interessieren. Was sind denn nun eigentlich wirklich die Kernkomponenten von Synthesisern, die sich so etabliert haben und die man so verstehen sollte, um überhaupt mal dahinterzukommen, was Klangerzeugung in der Regel so ausmacht?
Da nehme ich jetzt mal eine längere Strecke hier für mich und fange mal an zu sprechen. Also der gewöhnliche Synthesizer, egal ob es der MOOC von vor 40 Jahren ist oder der billige Kork sowieso von heut zutage von einer Tankstelle für 500 Euro oder ob bei Lidl oder das Luxusmodell oder was weiß ich.
Lidl gibt Synthesizer?
Lidl ist der größte Musikfachverkäufer in Irland.
Unser Discounter, Supermarkt Lidl.
Also ich habe in Irland auf einem Workshop gearbeitet, habe ich einen Prospekt gesehen, der verkauft Lidl, hat einen eigenen Prospekt oder ich glaube, das war Lidl oder irgendeine Bude. Vielleicht war es Aldi, nee ich glaube, es war Lidl, aber das war ein achtseitiger Prospekt, der ging in alle Haushalte, da war ein Schlagzeug, eine Bassgitarre, ein Dings und all so ein Zeug war da drin und das kauft man dann heutzutage da. Ja, so ist die Welt. Und wenn das dann alle machen und denken, super, ist ja billig und mein Junge wollte ja immer schon mal, in Irland gibt es kein Fachgeschäft mehr. Das größte Fachgeschäft, was in Finnland für Musikinstrumente zuständig ist, sitzt in Deutschland.
Ach, also das ist nicht, bis jetzt nicht du.
Das ist Europa, das bin nicht ich. Nee, das will ich auch nicht sein. Aber die haben ja auch nicht alles. So, da sind wir wieder zurück beim Rauschen. Es rauscht eben auch in Finnland manchmal und Schnee und Wind haben die ja auch und deswegen wollen die auch sowas natürlich haben für ihre Filmmusik.
Rauschen ist doch jetzt schon eine relativ komplexe Angelegenheit, oder?
Na ja, aus Rauschen kann ich irgendwie zum Beispiel, wenn ich das an verschiedenen Stellen abgreife, zum Beispiel eine Zufallsspannung machen. Also wenn ich ein...
Soweit ich das irgendwie verstanden habe, das Einfache, was man jetzt erst mal so erzeugen kann, also wenn man auch erst mal anfängt, so was zu bauen, sind eigentlich so normale Sinus-Frequenzen.
Schwingungen.
Schwingungen halt.
Oszillatoren.
Genau.
Selbstschwinger, wie man auch so schön sagen könnte.
Fängt es nicht damit an? Ich meine, man fängt ja nicht... Damit fängt es an. Dann fangen wir doch damit mal an.
Zack, da haben wir ein Rechteck. Es gibt Oszillatoren, die machen schnell und die machen langsam. Und ob sie schnell oder langsam machen, das kann ich steuern. Und das macht sie vom Oszillator zum Voltage Controlled Oszillator, weil ich die Frequenz eines Oszillatoren mit einer anderen Frequenz oder mit einer Spannung steuern kann.
Was schwingt denn da?
Da schwingt ein Schaltkreis. Ich denke, das ist irgendwelches Gelöt aus Kondensatoren und Transistoren, wo sich irgendwas belegt und wieder entlädt und wieder belegt und wieder entlädt. Und die Geschwindigkeit dessen, die kann ich wahrscheinlich steuern, dadurch, dass ein Strom zugeführt wird, mehr oder weniger.
Dass sozusagen eine Spannung variiert wird.
Und ich mach das mal. Also ich habe zum Beispiel hier einen Möchtegernsinus. Den kann ich in seiner Oktavlage verändern.
Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt mal hier das erste Mal meine Position verändern, mir das mal von der Seite angucken. Ganz interaktive Sendung heute hier im Stehen.
Sehr schön. Also ich habe hier jetzt mal so einen Standard-Ostellator von der Firma Döpfer. Der liefert hier vier Ausgänge und da sind Symbole dran. Das eine ist eine Sinuswelle. Da kommt sowas raus.
So klingt es.
Der zweite Ausgang ist ein Dreieck.
Klingt fast genauso.
Der dritte Ausgang ist ein Rechteck. Das klingt ein bisschen schärfer. Und der vierte Ausgang ist ein Sägezahn. Das klingt so.
Das sind eigentlich so die klassischen Hüllkurven, die man eigentlich so verwenden kann.
Nicht Hüllkurven, das sind Wellenformen.
Ja, wenn schön.
Und der Sägezahn ist recht scharf. Ich stelle ihn mal ein bisschen tiefer. Die Pulsweite hat die meisten Obertöne. Also das lernen wir teilweise auch im Mathematikunterricht, dass man jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Rechteck, wo oben eine Flanke ist und unten eine Flanke ist, das kann ich mir definieren aus einer Summe seiner Obertöne, die allesamt Sinen sind, also Sinusse. Wenn ich jetzt sage, von einem Rechteck ziehe ich einen Sinus mit gleicher Frequenz ab, dann bleiben zwei kleinere Sinusse über, also die halbe, die doppelte Frequenz, dann auch noch abgezogen und dann nochmal, davon brauche ich dann aber zwei und von der nochmal, davon halbierten, brauche ich dann aber vier und so weiter und daraus definieren sich die Obertöne. Und das Rechteck-Signal hat am meisten Obertöne, während der Sinus, wenn er denn rein ist, eigentlich gar keine Obertöne hat, weil das eine ausgewogene Schwingung ist.
Der reine Ton.
Genau. Und wenn ich mir einen sauberen Sinus mache, das erkläre ich gleich nochmal, wenn wir beim Filter angekommen sind, aber jetzt erstmal zurück zum Oszillator. Bei diesem Oszillator, den ich hier vor mir habe, da gibt es dann so verschiedene Stellschrauben, also Potentiometer, mit denen ich was verändern kann. Die erste davon hat Einfluss auf die Oktavlage und der zweite davon hat Einfluss auf so ein bisschen Tonhöhe. Das kann gut und schlecht sein, ich kann aber offensichtlich nicht die Töne dazwischen erwischen. Also wenn ich mit dem Tune-Regler ganz nach oben und ganz nach unten gehe, dann habe ich ja einen Abstand generiert, der nicht mal zwei Tönen entspricht. Klar habe ich dann noch den Oktavwahlschalter, der da drüber liegt, aber ich kann eben nicht, wie bei einem anderen Oszillator, den ich daneben habe, recht weg, ganz nach unten, ganz nach oben und über mehrere Oktaven hin und her hüpfen. Das ist ein kleines Detail.
Das heißt, so unterscheiden sich halt auch diese Module. Also Döpfer ist jetzt so ein deutscher Hersteller.
Die sitzen in München, ja genau. Ja genau, Herr Dieter Döpfer hat sich da vor zwölf Jahren viel Gedanken gemacht und hat dieses preiswerte inzwischen größte Modularsystem oder populärste Modularsystem der Welt in seiner Dimension, eher das kleinste, nicht das kleinste, aber eins der kleineren, entwickelt.
Also kompakt, aber vielfältig.
Genau, sehr vielfältig geworden, weil er auch schlauerweise sehr offen mit seinen Normen umgeht und sagt, ja hier wieso, das sind die und die Stecker, die kannst du da und da kaufen. Und das mache ich mal so und so. Und da ist der und der Strom. Und so und so breit müssen die Maße sein, damit man da ein Modul reinbauen kann.
Also ist alles wohl spezifiziert?
Ja, ist alles wohl spezifiziert. Und der ganz große glückliche Umstand, der auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen dem geschuldet sind, dass wir alle so aktiv dafür werben, ist, dass diverse kleine Hersteller aus Schweden, Amerika, Deutschland und sonst woher, Module bauen, die genau hier reinpassen. Die hinten die gleichen Stecker haben, die vorne die gleichen Maße haben, die in ihrer Breite variieren. Manche sind schwarz, manche sind grün, manche sind weiß und manche sind silber und unterschiedliche Töne. Aber sie passen alle und sie funktionieren alle miteinander. Das heißt, ich kann neben den unzähligen Döpfer-Modulen und den, was weiß ich, 20, 30 Döpfer filtern, noch einen Filter von irgendjemandem kaufen, der meint, er könne diese Disziplin womöglich besser und es fehlt aber in all diesen Döpfer-Filtern noch einer, der dann auch noch Lambada kann oder was weiß ich.
Okay, das heißt, wir haben jetzt hier zwei Oszillatoren, VCOs, Spannungsgesteuerte Oszillatoren, die im Wesentlichen dasselbe tun, das heißt in der Lage, einen von mehreren Wellenformen zu erzeugen, in verschiedenen Tonhöhen und die Geräte unterscheiden sich im Wesentlichen darin, welche Einstellungsschrauben man so hat.
Ja, und welche zusätzlichen Parameter ich, wie viele Eingänge ich connecten kann, aber auch teilweise durch die Qualität ihrer auszugebenden Wellenform. Ich könnte mir jetzt ein Oszilloskop anschließen und würde dann sehen, dass das Rechteck von dem einen Hersteller womöglich eine gradere Flanke oben hat als das Rechteck von dem anderen Hersteller. Ich würde sehen, dass der Sinus von dem einen Hersteller in der Mitte seiner Spitze nicht wirklich einem Sinus entspricht, sondern eine kleine Beule hat, weil es kein reiner Sinus ist, sondern weil das nur so ungefähr ein Sinus ist und weil dann der Hersteller sagt, ach, das hört man doch sowieso nicht, weil das geht doch noch durch drei Filter. Oder dass dann ein Oszillator einen Tune-Regler hat, der eben nicht nur von ganz links bis ganz rechts geht, sondern den nicht zehnmal im Kreis drehen kann. Und dann kommt er erst an seinen Anschlag, um ganz fein regeln zu können, was da für eine Frequenz gerade rauskommt. So, und jetzt aber noch mal eben einen Schritt weiter. Wir reden ja nicht von Oszillatoren, sondern wir reden von spannungsgestellten Oszillatoren, sogenannten VCOs, weil sie Voltage-controlled sind. Das heißt, dass sich die Frequenz dieses Selbstschwingers beeinflussen kann durch eine anzulegende Steuerspannung. Und dafür haben diese Oszillatoren dann einen Eingang, der heißt CV. Da stecke ich jetzt mal bei einem der Oszillatoren von einer englischen Firma einen Kabel in den CV-Eingang.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen die Control Voltage.
Genau. Und da kann ich jetzt die Steuerspannung. Da kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel das Dreieck von dem anderen Oszillator anschließen.
Das heißt, der eine erzeugt einen Dreieck und dieses Dreiecksignal geht in den anderen Oszillator rein als Steuerspannung, der aber selber einen Rechteck jetzt erzeugt. Das heißt, das Rechteck wird durch das Dreieck gesteuert.
Ganz genau. Und das ist dann eine Frequenzmodulation, weil beide einzelnen Spannungen im Audio Bereich sind. Wenn ich jetzt aber den steuernden Oszillator ganz runter drehe, dann merke ich, dass der die Tonhöhe ganz schnell rauf und runter regelt. Das ist jetzt seine tiefste Frequenz, die der regeln kann. Ich gehe nochmal zurück und lasse uns den nochmal hören. Das ist der Dörpfer-Ozillator. Der geht genau bis dahin runter.
Das ist jetzt der tiefste und den nehmen wir jetzt gleich als Steuerspannung.
Den nehmen wir jetzt als Steuerspannung und schicken den in den anderen. Und damit haben wir da dann so was. Jetzt mache ich das gleiche mal andersrum und sage, ich nehme das Rechteck vom Dörpfer, drehe den in den Hörbandbereich und gebe dem einen CV von dem ersten und drehe den ganz runter. Der kann also auch nicht ganz runter. Das heißt, wir kommen also nicht tief genug, um zum Beispiel einfach hinzukriegen. Und dafür nehmen wir jetzt dann irgendwas anderes, nämlich unsere Antenne, die wir vorhin schon mal hatten.
Das Teremin.
Das Teremin, diese Teremin-Antenne, die kann ja eine Kronenhöhe.
Also das ist auch nur so ein Modul von Dörpfer, hast du ja auch schon gesagt. Das hat auch nur zwei Regler, also zwei Putis.
Genau. Und der generiert in Abhängigkeit der Nähe meiner Hand zur Antenne, generiert dann eine Steuerspannung. Und eine Steuerspannung, um das nochmal zu definieren, ist einfach eine Spannung in diesen Fällen zwischen 0 und 5 Volt. Also wenn ich da nicht dran bin und den richtig eingestellt habe, den ganz runterdrehe, dann ist da 0 Volt. Wenn ich da dann rankomme, dann dreh ich den hoch, da kann ich den so ein bisschen einstellen, dass der richtig reagiert.
Das ist im Prinzip das Beispiel, was wir dahin schon gebracht haben. Das funktioniert.
Und das steuert ein Oszillator.
Ich geh jetzt mit der Hand da rein.
Und so kann ich da...
Damit wir das hören, geht das jetzt nochmal in ein anderes Modul, nämlich in ein Mixer-Modul, also das, was wir am Ende auch brauchen, verschiedene Klänge dann auch zu mixen.
Genau, das ich im Moment dafür benutze, um immer mal ein bisschen leise zu machen, damit dem joggenden Fahrradfahrer das Ding nicht von da rüber knallt, wenn ich das Kabel reinstecke.
So, das ist jetzt sozusagen erstmal die Funktionalität.
Genau, den benutze ich jetzt aber trotzdem mal für die Steuerspannung von dem einen Oszillator, der dann mit seinem Rechteck den anderen Oszillator und dann da wieder raus.
Das heißt, jetzt hast du eine Kaskade aus zwei Steuerspannungen. Das Therémin liefert die Steuerspannung für den ersten Oszillator, der dann wiederum mit seinem Ergebnis die Steuerspannung für den zweiten Oszillator liefert.
Ja, genau. Ich höre gerade nicht so viel.
Muss hier mal an die Antenne rangehen. Wenn ich nah ran bin, ist es so, wenn ich jetzt weiter weggehe, wird es schräg.
Das ist jetzt gar nicht so sexy. Wenn man das hören, ist immer die Frage, die man sich stellen muss. Will man das wirklich hören? Wollen wir das wirklich wissen? Jetzt mache ich mal den da auch noch rein. Und jetzt mache ich mal einen... Ach so, da fällt mir auch noch ein tolles Experiment rein, eine Cross-Modulation. Warum können die denn nicht? Der eine macht den einen und der andere macht den anderen. Das ist doch überhaupt das Beste, was wir haben. Also gehen wir aus dem Rechteck da raus. Und jetzt sagen wir, das Rechteck vom einen steuert den anderen und das Rechteck vom anderen steuert den einen. So, und dann wird es richtig sportlich. Dann brauche ich nämlich gar nichts mehr anzufassen.
Das heißt, jetzt modelliert sich das alles gegenseitig, wenn man nutzt da die verschiedenen Ausgänge. Oh man, aber so richtig überzeugenden Technosound habe ich jetzt noch nicht gehört.
Nee, darum geht es ja auch nicht. Jetzt kann ich aber nochmal klar machen, was für einen Einfluss auch die geringsten Drehbewegungen haben. Ach so, der ist ja zu. So, jetzt haben wir aber was.
Mach mal aus. Eine Sache hast du nicht erläutert. Wir haben jetzt ja noch eine Filtergeschichte drin gehabt.
Genau, den hatte ich eben versehentlich. Den hatte ich die ganze Zeit noch drin, weil ich vorhin ja das Rauschen gefiltert hatte und da noch das Kabel drin stecken hatte.
Das heißt, alles, was wir gehört haben, stimmt da alles gar nicht. Wir müssen noch mal vorne anfangen.
Nein, doch, doch. Das war schon ungefähr... Es ging ja auch nur um die Steuerspannung bis jetzt und um die Tonhöhe von Oszillatoren grundsätzlich.
Okay, dann können wir ja vielleicht mal jetzt hier auch zu den Filtergeschichten kommen. Weil das ist ja dann immer so das nächste, was man nimmt, oder?
Ja, genau. Hier habe ich zum Beispiel den, oder einen der billigsten preiswertesten, sagt man ja als Verkäufer, Entschuldigung, den preiswertesten Filter der Firma Döpfer, den WASP-Filter im System, den ich sehr gern habe, der allerdings leider nicht selber pfeifen kann, also so eigenresonanzfähig ist. Das erläutere ich mal deshalb an einem anderen Beispiel. Und nehmen wir mal...
Also was ist denn die eigentliche Aufgabe eines Filters?
Das ist das ganze System, was wir hier vor uns sehen, das nennt natürlich subtraktive Synthese, weil man dauernd irgendwas abzieht. Und der Filter ist eigentlich der Inbegriff des Abziehens, weil der nimmt Frequenzen weg. Und der nimmt entweder die hohen Frequenzen oder die mittleren Frequenzen oder die tiefen Frequenzen weg und schneidet sie an einer sogenannten Eckfrequenz, der Cutoff Frequency, ab. Und wenn er die tiefen Frequenzen abschneidet, dann nennt man ihn einen Hochpass-Filter. Wenn er die hohen Frequenzen abschneidet, nennt man ihn einen Tiefpass-Filter.
Weil der Tiefe kommt durch, also es ist ein Tiefpass. Also Tiefpass macht hoch weg und Hochpass macht tief weg.
Dann gibt es noch einen Bandpass, der ein schmales Band passieren lässt. Und dann gibt es noch einen...
Also ein Frequenzband, ein Vonbiss-Bereich.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch die Antipathie davon, das Notch, was ein Kerbfilter hieße in deutscher Sprache, der eine Kerbe aus dem Frequenzband rausschneidet.
Was ist das jetzt was anderes als ein Bandfilter?
Also der Bandpass lässt ein schmales Band passieren. Der schneidet unten mit einem Hochpassfilter ab.
Achso, verstehe, das ist sozusagen das Gegenteil. Also beim Band bleibt das Band über und beim Notch bleibt dieses Band nicht über.
Genau, da wird das Band weggenommen.
Verstehe.
So und jetzt nehme ich mal hier einen Tester.
So einen Notchfilter könnte man zum Beispiel benutzen, wenn man so einen 50-Hertz-Brum irgendwo drin hat. Dass man den halt einfach auf diese 50-Hertz anlegt und dann sind die 50-Hertz weg, oder?
Ja, das geht. Das wäre denkbar. Ich kenne diese Filter hier auch alle nicht so richtig. Ich nehme einfach hier...
Vielleicht noch mal zur Erklärung. Also wir haben jetzt hier locker 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, so 20, 24 verschiedene Module hier klemmen.
Das sind zwei kleine Koffer voll, die übrigens Handgepäcks tauglich sind für Vielflieger, die sich gerne hier oder da mit elektronischer Musik beschäftigen. 6 HE-Koffer, das sind die kleinen Döpfer-Cases, die dadurch bezeichnet sind, dass sie mit Kabeln verschließbar sind. Also man kann seine Patches, wie sich das nennt, also so wie die Kabel in den Koffern unter den Modulen dann stecken, die kann man einfach stecken lassen, macht den Deckel drauf, fliegt irgendwo hin, macht den Deckel ab, steckt die Audioverbindung ran und los geht's. Genau. Ja, das ist dann der Ersatz für Total Recall. Ich höre da auf, wo ich aufgehört habe, ziehe nur ein Kabel raus, mache den Deckel zu und mache den woanders wieder drauf. Das ist geil. Habe ich heute nicht gemacht, weil ich mit dieser Kombination noch nicht gearbeitet habe. Insofern ist das hier eher ein bisschen experimental.
Das Thema ist sozusagen in seiner Konfiguration persistent.
Siehst du, wie der was hier... Ja, stimmt. Wunderbar. So, jetzt nehme ich mal hier einen Filter. Da kommt phänomenalerweise gerade gar nichts raus, was mich sehr erstaunt. Das prüfe ich noch mal. Das Schöne ist, dass man immer einfach ein Kabel reinsteckt und sagt, okay, das ist der Eingang, das ist der Ausgang, da kommt nichts. Das heißt, da habe ich vielleicht vergessen hinten, doch, da kommt was. Aber sehr seltsam.
Irgendwas machen, was nicht ganz so kratzt und scharpt. Muss doch auch schön gehen.
Was ist denn jetzt mit der Quelle?
Ach, du hast jetzt noch dieses komische... Nimm mal noch mal so ein reines Rechteck oder so. Das ist toll. Wir arbeiten jetzt mal mit so einem reinen Rechteck. Genau, was angenehm ist, was man gut hören kann.
Da hört man sowieso was und das wollte ich hören. Das wollte ich nämlich darstellen. Hier ist ein Filter von der Firma Wired. Das ist so ein Ami, der lange Tretminen gebaut hat, also so Gitarren-Fußboden-Effekte und dann festgestellt hat, ach Mensch, wieso, wenn ich das in Module baue, dann habe ich plötzlich 30 neue Freunde, weil die Leute, die Module benutzen, auch meistens mit den Gitaristen auf Kriegsfuß sind und dann so Tretminen nicht haben wollen. Das wandelt sich aber gerade so ein bisschen. Und die Firma Malekko wollte ich sagen. Quatsch, Entschuldigung. Also Malekko sind zwei Herren aus den USA, die ihrerseits Filter nachbauen von der Firma Wired, die für ganz besondere Filterschaltungen einen gewissen Ruhm erlangt hat. Und eine davon ist der Boogie-Filter, den ich jetzt hier vor mir habe.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt die normale Rechteckspannung eigentlich angelegt. Die klingt jetzt erstmal ohne Filter. Wie?
Ohne Filter klingt sie... da komme ich nicht ran. Nehmen wir mal die, damit wir das Original vergleichen können. Das Kabel war jetzt zu kurz in dem Fall. Das ist das Original. Das kommt jetzt hier wieder raus aus dem Filter. Ist so? Wenn ich den Cutoff-Frequenz ganz hoch drehe. Das heißt, in diesem Fall haben wir hier einen Tiefpass-Filter. Jetzt drehe ich mal ein bisschen runter und dann gehen plötzlich die hohen Frequenzen verloren.
Und klingt doch nicht mehr so nervig. Das hat man einfach......bleiben über... .den Tiefanteil.
Diese Eckfrequenz, die Cutoff-Frequency, die kann ich mit dem Finger drehen, so wie ich das jetzt tue, wenn ich halt an dem Regler drehe. Ich kann aber auch diese Eckfrequenz natürlich modulieren lassen von einem Oszillator, der sich ganz langsam bewegt. Das mache ich jetzt mal. Dafür habe ich einen LFO genommen, der ganz langsam schwingt. Also wieder ein Oszillator, der aber die Sonderbesonderheit hat, dass er nur für tiefe Frequenzen ausgesucht ist.
Der ist jetzt nicht voltage controlled, sondern er erzeugt halt einfach nur eine tiefe Frequenz. In diesem Fall ein Dreieck und dieses Dreieck kann man hier wunderbar hören, wie es sozusagen immer, wenn es oben ist, erzeugt es viel Steuerspannung und in dem Moment setzt dieser Filter anders ein als das ohnehin schon tut.
Da verändert sich die Eckfrequenz nach oben.
Die Cutoff-Frequenz.
Genau und den Einfluss dessen kann ich hier auch noch verändern am Filter. Und dann kann ich noch auf die Eckfrequenz eine Resonanz dazu regeln, wo an der Eckfrequenz das Signal sozusagen kurzgeschlossen wird, nochmal addiert wird und dann der...
Das ist jetzt dieser Wow-Wow-Effekt, den ich jetzt aufdrehe.
Jetzt auf volle Pulle und jetzt ist er ganz weg. Dann habe ich nur das Original-Signal und wenn ich die Resonanz aufdrehe, dann hat er eine eigene Resonanz und zwar genau an der Eckfrequenz, die ja jetzt moduliert wird. Jetzt nehme ich die Modulation nochmal raus. Und diese eigene Resonanz von einem Filter, die wäre, wenn ich jetzt kein Eingangssignal mehr habe, indem ich das Rechteck rausziehe und da hören wir die, das ist ein reiner Sinus. Das ist im Prinzip so ein Kurzschluss. Das ist ein Sinus. Wenn ich einen Sinus brauche, kann ich also einen Filter nehmen und kann über die Steuerspannung, die anliegt vom LFO und den Sinus moduliert, kann ich eben auch den Sinus mit einem Sequencer oder mit einem anderen Modul oder mit einem Keyboard, was eine Steuerspannung generiert, spielen. Und jetzt haben wir wieder die rechte Kurve als Eingang.
Die sozusagen in den Filter reingeht und dieser Sinus, den wir da eben am Pulsen hören, der beschäftigt sich jetzt damit.
Ein anschauliches Beispiel für die Anwendung eines Filters ist natürlich auch, dass man einfach externe Signale durch einen Filter jagen kann, wie zum Beispiel eine Rhythmusmaschine oder... Das wollen wir jetzt nicht. Entschuldigung, ich muss mal eben hier ein bisschen experimentieren.
Jetzt wird hier viel geschraubt.
Ich drücke einfach mal auf den Knopf.
Also VCO, LFO und die Filter, das ist schon im Prinzip das Wesentliche, eigentlich was man immer zum Einsatz bringt.
Ja, es gibt dann natürlich noch den Voltage Controlled Amplifier, weil sonst jammert ja die ganze Zeit meine Frequenz da im Hintergrund rum. Und um da draus eine Melodie zu machen, will ich ja noch An-Aus haben. Und An-Aus generiere ich durch einen VCA, einen Voltage Controlled Amplifier, der entweder verstärkt oder eben nicht verstärkt.
Das heißt, wenn Strom dann irgendwie laut und wenn nicht Strom, dann nicht laut. Das heißt, damit hat man sozusagen eine Taste.
Ja, genau. Und die Tastenbewegung kann ich auch in Abhängigkeit von einem LFO auslösen, indem ich dann sage, das Signal geht eben hier durch einen VCA.
Also auch der VCA ist hier ein Modul und ist nicht ein Keyboard, wie man es vielleicht vermuten möchte.
Kriegt dann von einem Rechteck aus dem LFO die Information, wann er an- und wann er auszugehen hat.
Das heißt, wir hören nach wie vor eigentlich dasselbe Signal wie eben, aber ein Rechteck, also quasi wie ein Schalter funktioniert, geht in diesen VCA rein, steuert den sozusagen und das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier die Frequenz hochdrehe, dann geht das so.
Genau. Und die kann ich im Prinzip so hochdrehen, dass die Frequenz von der Laut- und Leiseschaltung ihrerseits wieder ein Ton ist. Wenn ich den LFO in den Audiobereich schalte. Obwohl ich jetzt ja den LFO eigentlich gar nicht höre, sondern das Gimob Brummer im Hintergrund.
Jetzt habe ich ihn ganz runter gedreht, da ist er noch so ein bisschen tastig und so, aber wenn er ein bisschen schneller wird, dann wird er schon eher zum eigenen Ton. Hier ist er wieder tastig. Jetzt haben wir schon so ein bisschen Musik hier, wenn ich das irgendwie in diesem niedrigen Frequenz mache. Das heißt, ihr habt jetzt eine niedrige Frequenz, eine niedrige Rechteck-Frequenz, die den VCA steuert, der wiederum das Signal steuert, was wir vorhin zusammen gemixt haben, und dann kommt da schon so ein bisschen Rhythmus. Immer noch nicht ganz Dancefloor-tauglich, aber you get the idea. Sprich, das sind jetzt sozusagen die Klassiker.
Ja, das wäre dann der Oszillator, den wir hatten, mit der Sonderform von LFO, dann die Filter. Was wir jetzt noch nicht hatten, war eine Hüllkurve. Das ist dann das letzte Element. Jetzt haben wir hier, ich ziehe mal eben das Rechteck raus und gehe mit dem Rechteck in den Gate-Eingang von einer ganz gewöhnlichen klassischen Hüllkurve, die ihrerseits vier Drehregler hat.
Jetzt hören wir aber nur das Rechteck. Den ganzen Filterkram von vorhin haben wir jetzt mal raus.
Der Filter macht den Sound. Das ist die Eigenresonanz vom Filter, die wir da hören. Das ist das Signal, das wir hören.
Jetzt komme ich durcheinander.
Okay, ich habe jetzt einfach den VCA aufgedreht. Dieser VCA hat den Luft.
Den nehmen wir mal langsam. Da hören ja auch noch Leute zu. Da müssen wir ja auch mal ein bisschen nachsichtig sein. Diese Hüllkurve können wir ja dann sicherlich auch erst mal erläutern, ohne den ganzen anderen Kram zu haben, oder?
Nein, weil die Hüllkurve macht eigentlich erst mal gar nichts. Wenn ich den Ausgang von der Hüllkurve an meinen Verstärker anschließe, passiert gar nichts. Die Hüllkurve generiert einen Strom, eine Steuerspannung, in Abhängigkeit von einer eingehenden anderen Steuerspannung.
Ach so, verstehe. Also so wie der normale VCA, jetzt wenn man ihn mal recht hinschickt, dann macht er halt an, aus, an, aus, an, aus, an, aus. Aber wenn ich sozusagen als Steuerspannung nicht ein Rechteck schicke, sondern eben das, was aus der Hüllkurve rauskommt, dann ist das sozusagen ein komplexer Tastendruck.
Genau, ich kann mit der Hüllkurve einen zeitlichen Verlauf definieren, mit einer Einschwingphase, einer Ausschwingphase, einem verbleibenden Niveau und einer Nachschwingphase.
Das nennt man dann ADSR.
Genau, die in Abhängigkeit von einem Startpunkt und einem Endpunkt stattfindet.
Also Attack ist sozusagen...
Attack ist die Einschwingphase, Decay ist die Abschwingphase.
Das heißt, es gibt zuerst mal ein starkes Anschwellen und Decay ist sozusagen dann das Maß, wie weit es davon erstmal wieder runtergeht.
Das Abschwellen vom Höchstpunkt, genau.
Dann Sustain.
Sustain ist ein Niveau, auf dem die Ausgabespannung verbleibt, bis zum Ende des Auslöseeffekts, also der eingehenden...
Tasten loslassen sozusagen.
Und dann gibt es noch die Nachschwingphase mit dem Namen Release. Dann, ja genau, das führ ich jetzt mal vor.
Das heißt, wir nehmen jetzt den Ton von eben, aber wir erhöhen ihn jetzt sozusagen in eine Kurve.
Genau, wir hatten diesen Ton. Ich mach den Ton, um nochmal eben abzuschweifen, ein bisschen spannender, indem ich da jetzt nicht diesen LFO nehme, sondern ein Wabern des Irgendwas. So, das ist jetzt das Eingangssignal.
Jetzt müssen wir auch halt klattern, wie das zustande kommt. Also das ist jetzt Random Noise.
Ja genau, ich habe jetzt einfach eine Zufallsspannung, weil dieses... einen dann doch eher an die herannahende Polizei erinnert. In das Eingangssignal von dem Ding stecke ich jetzt auch mal wieder. Da stecke ich jetzt mal ein Rhythmus. Das ist überhaupt eine super Idee. Du sagst immer, das ist ja alles nicht Techno genug. Techno gibt es heute nicht, aber ich mache hier mal ein bisschen... Ich habe hier so eine Ballerbude mitgebracht von meinem Freund Herrn Fricke aus Zehlendorf.
Ein Drumcomputer.
Genau. Der kann...
Kleines schwarzes Plastik-Gerät mit vielen Knöpfchen.
Humba-Bumba machen.
Drumcomputer sind ein Prinzip musikinstrumente, elektronische Musikinstrumente, weil sie sich darum geht, ein rhythmisches Gerät zu erzeugen. Und meistens hat es mit Bum-Bum zu tun.
Und der kann eben kein Lambada.
Das heißt, der hat so komplette Rhythmus.
Das muss man da auch alles aus analogen Klang-Ezeugern zusammenschrauben. Das ist dann die Miniature-Spar-Variante von drei Analog-Synthesizer und Rauschen und die Snare-Drumm, die ich hier drin höre in der Kombination des Rhythmus, ist auch nichts anderes als ein Rauschen mit dem Filter hinten dran, aber eben vorkonfiguriert und da kann ich die einzelnen Komponenten nicht mehr abgreifen. Insofern ist es dann schon ein schönes Beispiel im Ergebnis. So, und diesen Rhythmus, den hören wir jetzt und den schneide ich jetzt ab durch den Filter. Der läuft jetzt durch den Borg-Filter von Wired, bzw. Malekku, Bougie-Filter, Entschuldigung. Es gibt auch einen Borg-Filter von dem. So, und jetzt wabert das da so ein bisschen hin. Und dieses Ergebnis, was wir da jetzt rauskriegen, das schicken wir jetzt in unseren VCA, der ja komplett geöffnet ist. So, jetzt mach ich den VCA wieder zu.
Dann hören wir nichts.
Dann hören wir nichts. Und dann nehmen wir wieder unser Rechteck. Und noch mal einmal zur Probe, das ist immer das Schöne.
Das ist jetzt das Rechteck, was sozusagen diesen Gesamtrhythmus, der da rauskommt, irgendwie ausmacht. Das klingt natürlich nicht so toll. Jetzt kommt das Rechteck aber in den ADSR rein. Das heißt, wir haben nicht nur dieses An-Aus, sondern das An-Aus, also diese Rechteckkurve, die wird jetzt von dem ADSR in eine etwas komplexere Kurve umgewandelt. Braucht dieses ADSR immer so eine Rechteckkurve als Eingang?
Bietet sich an, weil man da einen klaren Start und einen klaren Endpunkt hat.
Verstehe.
Aber ich hänge an das Fest, mit meinem Rhythmus bin ich total bekloppt, weil das irritiert, wenn man verstehen will, was die ADSR macht. Ich gehe zurück auf meinen Rechteck. Jetzt haben wir wieder das Rechteck. Das ist viel geiler. Vergessen wir das mal mit der Rhythmusmaschine und mit dem Techno. Das ist eh alles Bullerballer. Wir sind da schließlich nicht zum Spaß hier, sondern wollen hier irgend wem was erklären. Das heißt, da haben wir jetzt wieder das Rechteck und die Laut- und Leisefunktion, wiederhole ich nochmal, ohne Höhekurve direkt in den VCA.
Genau, das ist jetzt relativ klar. Also wir haben jetzt hier die Rechteckkurve und die macht einfach an, aus, an, aus, an, aus. Das ist das, was der VCA jetzt tut. Und jetzt schließen wir dazwischen ADSR. Das heißt, das ADSR-Modul, das Höhekurven-Modul verändert diese Rechteckspannung in einen etwas elaborierten Lautstärkeverlauf.
So, jetzt hören wir schon die Einschwingphase, die relativ weich ist. Die habe ich jetzt mal auf Null gedreht.
Dann ist sie immer noch sehr rechteckig. Und jetzt, wenn ich die Attackphase hochdrehe, dann wird sie immer matschiger, dass man es gar nicht mehr hört.
Bis die Attackphase länger ist als der Ton an sich. Die eingehende Gatelänge ist dann, ich mache den Ton mal ein bisschen langsamer.
Jetzt mache ich noch mal ganz runter. Jetzt hört man richtig, dass es rechteckig reinschlagen. Jetzt drehe ich den Attack langsam hoch. Jetzt wird er immer matschiger. Jetzt schiebt er sich so richtig rein. Man merkt, dass so die eine Kante schon so richtig abgeschliffen ist. Was können wir jetzt weitermachen?
Jetzt können wir die Decay-Phase erklären. Wenn ich die Decay- und Sustain auf Null drehe, dann höre ich nur noch die Attack-Phase, die dann damit aufhört und damit ist der Ton zu Ende. Jetzt drehe ich die Attack-Phase runter, habe nur ein kurzes Klick.
Jetzt haben wir nur noch einen Knacken.
Und auf den Klick folgt jetzt die Decay-Phase, die sich genau andersherum verhält, nämlich abschwingt.
Also nicht wie bei dem Attack eben hoch, sondern runter. Jetzt haben wir nur Decay sozusagen.
Genau, ein Dreieck abwärts. Die drehe ich auch wieder kurz. Und jetzt drehe ich die Sustain-Phase auf. Und merke, dass aufgrund... Nach dem Ende dieser jetzt sehr kurzen Decay-Phase ist ein stehender Ton im Hintergrund. Das ist die Sustain-Phase. Das ist das Sustain-Level. Das ist der einzige Parameter, der nicht durch seine Zeit beschrieben wird, sondern durch seine Intensität.
Also durch die Lautstärke.
Und wenn der zu Ende ist, ist ja...
Der Release, und dann ist auch gleich zu Ende.
Und dann ist der Release...
Wenn wir den jetzt hochdrehen...
Die Zeit... Dann läuft's aus... .die danach noch schwingt.
Soll ich mal nicht ganz so extrem?
Jetzt nehme ich einen weg.
Ich hab die Tasse sozusagen rausgezogen, damit dann keiner mehr kam, dass er noch so nachhaltig ist. Also der Release ist dann sozusagen einfach der Ausklang. So, jetzt kann man sozusagen den Attack noch mal ein bisschen weicher machen. Vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr Decay, dann braucht er auch länger, bis er wieder runterkommt. Den Ton insgesamt ein bisschen kürzer. So näher hat man sich sozusagen dann dem Ton, den man haben will.
Genau, aber das ist ja nun nur ein banaler Ton. Wenn ich jetzt aber zum Beispiel einen Spannungsverlauf machen möchte... Mach mal aus.
Das sind mal die Ohren der Hörer auch mal kurz schon.
Genau, und wenn ich jetzt aber zum Beispiel einen Spannungsverlauf über 20 Minuten haben will, weil ich Mike Oldfield habe und gerade irgendwie meine 30-Minuten-Performance live mit irgendwas oder Tender in Dream und irgendwie ganz langsam soll die Lampe angehen und am Ende soll sie am tollsten sein, dann brauche ich eine Höhlkurve, die eben längere Phasen oder andere Zeiten machen kann. Es kann auch sein, dass ich eben mit dieser Regelbarkeit zwischen Puck und Poing noch nicht zufrieden bin, sondern auch noch zwischen Pick und Puck und Puck und Puck und Puck unterscheiden möchte. Und dann brauche ich einfach eine andere...
Den verleiht man häufig, ja.
Ja, das gibt es wirklich, weil das macht die klangliche Bewertung, ob es sich dabei nun um eine Orgel oder um eine Panflöte handelt, macht der erste Impuls des Geräusches aus. Und wenn ich tatsächlich dann dadurch Einfluss nehme, dass ich eine Höhekurve zwischen Puck, Puck, Puck, Puck, Puck unterscheiden lasse, die auf den Filter wirkt, dann kann ich damit sehr große Sachen bewirken. Diese Höhekurve, die wir jetzt hier sehen, anhand derer wir das erklärt haben, hat einen Bereichsschalter, wo wir jetzt im mittleren Bereich waren. Die hat aber auch einen tiefen Bereich für die, ich glaube, bis zu zwei, drei Minuten Verläufe. Und dann hat sie einen hohen Bereich, wo man dann eben wirklich ganz feine Unterschiede bei einem Decay zwischen ganz kurzen und weniger kurzen Bereichen darstellen kann. Ich mache das nochmal kurz an. Das ist jetzt der hohe Bereich der Höhekurve, die ich jetzt... Ach so, hoher Bereich heißt genau das andersrum. Das ist der Bereich, den ich meine, das ist der Low-Bereich, weil das natürlich die kürzeste Gesamtzeit ist. Und da bin ich auf 9 Uhr jetzt, da bin ich jetzt auf 12 Uhr, da bin ich jetzt auf 3 Uhr und jetzt bin ich beim Vollanschlag von Decay. Jetzt drehe ich das wieder runter, schalte um auf H, Stellung H und bin jetzt auf 9 Uhr, bin jetzt auf 12 Uhr, gehe jetzt auf 15 Uhr, da geht es schon gar nicht mehr weiter. Jetzt gehe ich auf Nähmittel. Habe ich an das falsch gemacht?
Jetzt passiert nichts mehr, egal wie man dreht.
Aha, das ist das. Die Gate-Länge war nicht lang genug.
Also jetzt hast du diesen... Dein LFO erzeugt jetzt einfach ein mega langsames Rechteck.
Genau.
Damit wir richtig...
Da ist gar kein Decay mehr zu erkennen, weil das fängt wahrscheinlich erst nach einer Minute an, langsam runterzugehen.
Dann lass mal runter nochmal. Ups, das ist aber jetzt alles sehr langsam.
Genau. Und im Low-Bereich ist die Decay-Kurve dann...
Kommt jetzt nochmal was?
So was. Das ist der Low-Bereich bei dieser Höhekurve. Noch einmal. Ja, kommt was. Das ist der M-Bereich. Jetzt habe ich umgeschaltet bei dieser Höhekurve.
Also kurz gesagt, ADS-R, man kann halt einfach damit sehr flexibel die Höhekurve reinmachen. Und es hat sich halt einfach so über diese Zeit, dieses ADS-R-Modell hat sich halt einfach herausgebildet. Man hätte ja auch ganz andere Rahmenparameter nehmen können, als jetzt ausgerechnet diese vier, oder?
Ja, es gibt auch Höhekurven, die haben zum Beispiel noch einen Holt-Parameter. Das heißt, der ist angesiedelt zwischen Attack und Decay und würde dann auf dem Level, was erreicht wird, wenn die Attack-Phase zu Ende ist, verbleiben für eine festzusetzende Zeit, um dann erst in die Decay-Phase runterzugehen, in der Decay-Phase wieder runter abzuschwingen. Dann gibt es noch den Parameter Delay, der zum Beispiel von Swamen in seiner Höhekurve ganz am Ende, in der Höhekurve im S1 auf jeden Fall, ganz am Ende steht, womit ich den gesamten Verlauf der Höhekurve nach hinten verlagern kann, um einen Ton abzubilden, dessen Filter dann womöglich erst nachdem der Ton schon eine Viertelsekunde normal steht, sich zu öffnen. Wenn ich dann Boack haben will, dann kann ich die Höhekurve mit einem Delay einstarten lassen und die Attack-Phase, die eben eine Viertelsekunde, nachdem der Ton schon da ist, dazu benutzen, um einen Filter zu öffnen oder die Tonhöhe zusätzlich nach oben zu modulieren.
Gut, jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Also was wir jetzt gezeigt haben in epischer Breite ist, man kann hier einfach nur durch das Verstöpseln der einzelnen Module einfach eine beliebige Kette von Klangerzeugung machen und alles, was irgendwie Klang erzeugt, kann im nächsten Moment auch nur dafür verwendet werden, die Klanggenerierung eines anderen Moduls zu steuern. Halt immer mit diesem Control Voltage sozusagen Eingang, das heißt jedes Modul, was so ein CV Eingang hat, da kann man dann halt einfach einen beliebigen Ausgang von irgendeinem anderen Modul reinstecken und damit beeinflusst man dann schon wieder, wie das andere funktioniert. Dann merkt man auch diese Unendlichkeit der Einflussnahme, was man eben noch so als Endprodukt für einen coolen Ton gehabt hat, benutzt man dann schon wieder nur, um das Modulationsverhalten eines Moduls zu beeinflussen von irgendeinem ganz anderen Ton, der damit vielleicht gar nichts zu tun hat. Da kann man sich ja richtig drin verlieren, also in diesem ganzen Apparatur. Jetzt hast du ja hier auch so ein Trautonium-Formand-Filter. Das heißt, das ist etwas, das klingt wirklich wie das Trautonium, oder was?
Das ist eine Komponente dessen, was auch das Trautonium hatte. Das ist ein vierfaches Filter, was in diesem Fall als Bandpass oder als Tiefpass angewendet werden kann. Jeder einzelne der vier Filterbänder. Beim Trautonium gab es den subharmonischen Generator, der in Abhängigkeit von der Frequenz des Master-Oscillators, ich zuppel mal hier die ganzen Kabel raus, das interessiert Tim. Warum interessiert euch das dann nicht auch? Also stecken wir das doch mal eben zusammen. Ich ruppel mal die Rhythmusmaschine wieder raus, das haben wir eindeutig abgewählt, und stecke hier mal die Kabel neu zusammen und nehme dafür...
Der Synthesizer-Freund braucht auf jeden Fall eine Menge Kabel, ne?
Ja, man hat immer mal so... Also vor allen Dingen ein bisschen Ordnung bei den unterschiedlichen Patch-Kabeln.
Also diese Stecker, wie auch die Kabel, die müssen ja alle extrem... Also die Buchsen und die Kabel, die müssen ja alle extrem solide gebaut sein, so viel wie da rein- und rausgesteckt wird.
Es gibt da unterschiedliche Qualitäten, aber nach einer gewissen Zeit hat man da Übung, wo man was wie reinsteckt. Die Qualitäten unterscheiden sich schon auch. Also selbst hier, der zum Beispiel hat hier so frontverschraubte... Das ist Livewire, der benutzt halt auch größere Knöpfe, lässt mehr Platz zwischen den verschiedenen Eingriffsmöglichkeiten. Da sieht man sehr viel mehr Frontplatte und benutzt so metallverschraubte und metallgehäusige Buchsen, wo man die Kabel reinstecken kann, im Gegensatz zu den Kunststoffbuchsen, die allerdings auch eine Metallverschraubung oben drauf haben von Töpfer. Also da gibt es deutliche Unterschiede. Das geht noch weiter, der Swamen Schwede benutzt.
Aber die sind jetzt nicht zwangensläufig schlechten, weil da jetzt Kunststoff dabei ist.
Nee, also es kommt auch auf die Art der Belastung an. Also diese Livewire-Regler auch, die mehr Platz brauchen auf der Platine. Das fühlt sich dann ganz anders an, wenn man da an so einem Knopf dreht. Die Schalter klingen auch so ohne Funktion. Schon mal anders als die von Döpfer oder die von... Wo haben wir denn noch mal? Hier haben wir noch Analog Sys Solutions. Haben wir gerade nichts mit Schalter. Und Frikke haben wir hier noch, MFB. Fühlt sich ganz viel weicher an. Aber das macht ja nichts. Kommt darauf an, wie oft ich daran rumschalte. Und wenn ich unbedingt einen tollen Schalter hab, kann ich mir auch einen Lichtschalter stellen.
Auf jeden Fall muss das schon mal halbwegs solide gebaut sein, weil sonst hat es ja irgendwie keinen Bestand. Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Trautonium. Das will ich jetzt unbedingt noch mal wissen, weil das ja sozusagen so der Blick in die Vergangenheit ist, wie man dann so am Anfang auch noch mal Sound gemacht hat. Zumindest so in etwa wie es klang.
Ich habe hier vorhin schon was reingesteckt, aber das ziehe ich mal eben wieder raus. Muss auch den Mut haben, immer wieder was rauszuziehen.
Genau, Mut zum rausziehen.
Genau, Mut zum rausziehen nach dem Motto, das kriege ich noch mal hin.
So, was haben wir denn hier? Also Trautonium, das sollen wir kurz hier mal erläutern, hat ganz viele Regler. Das macht die Sache natürlich schwer zu erklären. Aber im Wesentlichen geht es hier darum, verschiedene Bänder zu beeinflussen und die dann immer auf dieselbe Art und Weise. Frequenz, Resonanz und Level. Und da gibt es dann vier. Und hat einen Input und hat einen Output. Das heißt, das Ding funktioniert als Filter.
Der Trautonium von Mant Filter ist ein Filter, wie das da auch drauf steht. Und der Filter, warte mal, das lassen wir so. Ich muss mal ein bisschen überlegen, was ich mir selber gemacht habe. So, jetzt hören wir da schon ein bisschen was.
Ein bisschen.
Genau. Input-Level auf, Output-Level auf. Das will ich aber auf Filmmusik hören. Na ja, warte mal, kommt doch auf den Film an.
Den will ich aber nicht haben.
So, jetzt kann ich da einen Filter aufdrehen.
Was schicken Sie denn da überhaupt rein?
Genau, ich schicke da rein das Ergebnis aus dem subharmonischen Generator, den der liebe Herr Dörpfer gebaut hat, auch zur Nachempfindung der Möglichkeiten mit einem Trautonium.
Da müssen wir uns aber jetzt erst mal den subharmonischen Generator anhören.
Nee, da fangen wir mal an mit der Quelle der Eingabe. Das ist mein Ribben-Controller, mein Positionssensor mit darunter liegendem Drucksensor, der zwei Steuerspannungen gibt, nämlich einmal die Steuerspannung, wo ich ihn anfasse, und mit der kontrolliere ich jetzt mal einen Oszillator. Das Ergebnis aus dem Oszillator, das wollen wir jetzt erst mal hören, und dafür stecke ich hier nochmal. Da haben wir das Ergebnis von dem Oszillator, den wir in seiner Frequenz über den Positionssensor steuern können.
Okay, also einmal über die Leiste rüber schubbern, macht diesen Hup.
Genau, da habe ich hier so eine Leiste von 50 cm, und je nachdem, wo ich den anfasse, verändert sich die Tonhöhe. Wenn ich ihn loslasse, springt er auf den tiefsten Wert zurück, weil er keinen veränderlichen Widerstand erfahren kann. So, und der Ton ist aber immer da. Und wenn ich nicht will, dass der Ton immer da ist, dann benutze ich einen Voltage Controlled Amplifier, wie wir das eben schon gelernt haben, und gehe mit dem Audiosignal aus dem Oszillator in den VCA und mit dem Ausgang vom VCA wieder zurück in meinen Mixer.
Was steuert den VCA jetzt?
Ja, bis jetzt noch gar nichts. Und dafür nehme ich jetzt aber mal den Drucksensor, der unter dem Ribbon-Controller liegt und kann damit dann sowohl die Tonhöhe als auch...
Das heißt, dieses Schiebeteil, da kann ich jetzt sozusagen durch das links-rechts Schieben die Tonhöhe beeinflussen und durch den Druck an der jeweiligen Stelle kann ich sagen... Jetzt drücke ich so... Drücke ich hier so drauf und das macht dann den Ton überhaupt an oder aus, egal wo ich gerade bin. Dann wird das ja auch gleich... Ist so ein sowas einfaches zu so einem super-universelen Musikinstrument. Das heißt, wenn man das jetzt hier irgendwie könnte, da mit zehn Fingern drauf zu spielen, kann ich hier mehrere... Ich kann hier mehrere Töne erzeugen, oder was?
Du kannst nur einen Ton erzeugen.
Aber ist das was anderes, wenn ich mit zwei drauf drücke?
Nee, dann verändert sich die Tonhöhe von dem einen.
Ach so, dann ist es dann wie so eine Mitte davon sozusagen.
Jetzt gebe ich das Ergebnis davon nochmal.
Also links, rechts schieben, macht Tonhöhe, drücken, macht Ton an, Ton aus in einem sozusagen. Das haben wir jetzt schon zusammengesteckt. Jetzt haben wir aber immer noch kein Trautonium.
Nee, genau, das Trautonium.
Aber wir haben Tonhöhe und an, aus.
Genau, und jetzt gehen wir mit dem Rechteck, das wir vom VCO generieren lassen, zuerst mal in den subharmonischen Generator. Der hat einen Rechteckeingang. Und aus dem Mixausgang dieses subharmonischen Generators gehen wir wieder dahin, wo wir eben waren.
Aber was ist denn denn eine subharmonische Generator? Nee, das ist nicht.
Doch, jetzt hören wir das. Der Oszillator, den wir dem subharmonischen Generator vorgeschaltet haben, definiert nach wie vor die Tonhöhe. Und der subharmonische Generator generiert die Subharmonien.
Das ist was?
Das ist... Ich drehe jetzt mal nur den subharmonischen Generator Nummer 1 auf und der hat einen Divisor, der Untertöne generiert. Das ist ein paralleles Universum zu den Obertönen, der Teilerfaktoren hat, die hier in einer kleinen Digitalanzeige angezeigt werden. Jetzt steht der auf 1. Ich habe nach wie vor die Lautstärke vom Original-Ozillator auf meinem Trautonium-Ribbon-Controller und kann jetzt den 1 als Unterton...
Wir fließen mit der Frequenzgenerierung, wie wir sie bisher hatten, in diesen supra-harmonischen Generator und der fügt sozusagen in Abhängigkeit von der Frequenz weitere Frequenzen hinzu.
So ist es, genau.
Die dann auch genauso klingen.
Ja, die genauso klingen, das sind alles Rechteckwellen, die der ausgibt.
Und ihr könnt dann so bis zu vier davon dazu machen. Das heißt, der Bereich hat im Prinzip das Ganze.
Nee, es wird nur ein komplexerer Ton.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt mache ich den Original-Ostellator ein bisschen höher.
Trautonium ist jetzt noch gar nicht dabei, ne?
Das ist jetzt der supra-harmonische Generator, der ein wesentliches Bestandteil des Original-Trautoniums wohl gewesen ist.
Aber das ist nicht mein Fachbereich. Demonstrieren wir das noch mal. Wir haben jetzt alles so zusammengebaut. Das Einzige, was jetzt hinzukam, ist der supra-harmonische Generator. Der macht jetzt in Abhängigkeit von der gedrückten Frequenz hier noch weitere hinzu. Dann klingt das auf einmal...
Subharmonien. Ich habe jetzt vier Subharmonien dazu.
Das klingt aber...
Dramatisch.
Ja, das hat schon so ein bisschen was von die Vögel gekommen. Na ja, okay.
Bis jetzt sind sie noch ziemlich am Boden. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal dramatisch.
Aber der volle trautonische Effekt stellt sich jetzt erst wahrscheinlich ein, wenn man diesen Formant-Filter...
Ja, und dann brauchen wir eigentlich noch einen Hall dazu. Hast du einen Hall? Ja, habe ich auch. Jetzt nehme ich den Filter noch mit dazwischen, der seinerseits ein vierfacher Filter ist, weil ich habe hier jetzt auch vier Subharmonien, die da kommen. Und jetzt kann ich natürlich versuchen, mit dem Bandpass-Filter Nummer eins zum Beispiel die Frequenz zu finden, die für mein Hörempfinden am schönsten, am herausstechendsten in diesem Originalklang des subharmonischen Bestandteils hat, neben den zweiten Bandpass-Filtern noch. Nehmen noch einen Tiefpass-Filter dazu.
Das heißt, dieser Trautonium-Filter, der filtert jetzt im Prinzip, substraktives Prinzip, einfach bestimmte Frequenzen auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise wieder heraus?
Ganz genau, aber durch die Eigenresonanz der Eckfrequenzen, die ich hier über einen Poti einstellen kann, der es da vier Stück gibt, füge ich auch wieder Sachen hinzu. Also jedes Filter kann über seine Eigenresonanz auch wieder an der einstellbaren oder zum Teil spannungssteuerbaren Eckfrequenz einen Anteil einer tonalen Geschichte hervorheben oder eben durch die Selbstoszillation dann auch was hinzufügen.
Das heißt, jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich nur noch einen Hall, damit es irgendwie richtig spacig klingt.
Können wir haben. Dann gehen wir nicht dahin, sondern dahin.
Wo gehen wir jetzt rein?
Jetzt gehen wir hier in einen Tip-Top Audio Z5000 Multi-Effect-Prozessor, der auch als Modul in diesem System integriert ist und der Hallern kann. Da haben wir es. Nee, ich muss mal hier zwei Dinge drehen.
Das heißt, das ist so ein Teil, da können ganz viele Effekte, verschiedene Hall-Sachen, da stellt man das mit so einem Drehregler ein und es hallt. Na das klingt ja natürlich jetzt schon richtig spaceig.
Vögelig. Irgendwie.
Vögelig.
Irgendwie schon so ein bisschen vögelig.
Er hat auf jeden Fall so eine ganz irre Tiefe dieser Halle, finde ich.
Da gibt es verschiedene Typen. Das sind dann, also ich meine, ich muss sagen, das ist dann tatsächlich dieser Halle, in dem Fall ist ein digitaler Effekt, aber macht ja nichts.
Ach so, geschummelt oder was?
Das ist, es gibt viele digitale Module inzwischen auch in diesem System, die dann die Sachen, die sich einfach digital besser machen lassen oder einfacher machen lassen, dann da mit integrieren. Und es gibt auch Module und es gibt auch Modularsysteme, die auf Speicherbarkeit sich versuchen. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch einen Pionier der Modularsystem-Zeiten namens Buchla, ein Amerikaner, der genauso alt ist, wie der Herr Moog jetzt wäre, wenn er noch leben würde. Der sehr, ein sehr prominentes System baut, das 200E, was versucht, komplette Speicherbarkeit von Modulen herzustellen, aber angeblich nicht immer funktioniert. Also es gibt da einen prominenten Anwender, der da so seine Schwierigkeiten mit hat, auch in Berlin, Kanadier seines Zeichens, Produzent von, wie heißt er, Richie Horton, genau. Der hat so eins und hat da wohl so und dann gab es einen. Das ist nicht so leicht, weil die ganzen Verbindungen, die man auf der Vorderseite hat, die muss man auf der Rückseite dann natürlich abspeichern und gleichzeitig handelt es sich dabei um richtige Ströme, die rein und rausgehen können und rein und rausgehen sollen. Ich bin kein Ingenieur, aber ich stelle mir das schon nicht ganz so leicht vor.
Ja, super. Ich denke, das war jetzt schon mal ein ganz cooler Walkthrough. Haben wir denn irgendwie ein wichtiges Modul vergessen, was jetzt, sagen wir mal, so zum Grundverständnis noch wichtig ist? Du hast ja jetzt noch diese anderen Geräte. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit nur an diesem modularen Köpferchen rumgeschraubt. Der Einsatz des Rhythmusgeräts war jetzt so ein bisschen zum falschen Zeitpunkt.
Ja, der war auch nicht so richtig geglückt, weil hier irgendwie die Synchronisation mit dem MIDI, das wieder in der digitalen Welt nicht so funktioniert hat, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Macht aber gar nichts. Ich habe hier noch mal mitgebracht einen kleinen Kompakt-Synthesizer, ebenfalls von der Firma Dörpfer, der seinerseits eigentlich auch nichts anderes ist, als ein kleines Modul mit einem Oszillator, einem Filter, einem VCA, zwei LFOs und einer ADSR-Höhlkurve an Bord und einem MIDI-to-CV-Interface. Und deshalb habe ich ihn auch mitgebracht, weil da ist ein MIDI-to-CV-Interface eingebaut, was ich benutzen kann, um da ein Keyboard anzuschließen oder meinen Computer und dann eine Tonfolge darin steuern kann, die dieses Interface wiederum als Steuerspannung für die Tonhöhe und als Steuerspannung für die Lautstärke ausgibt.
Das heißt also, man würde typischerweise ein MIDI-Keyboard anschließen?
Man würde typischerweise ein MIDI-Keyboard anschließen oder aber eben, wenn man jetzt unbedarft ohne weitere Keyboard-Kenntnisse an elektronische Musik gerät oder geraten möchte, seinen Computer, womöglich einen Ableton, läuft, was MIDI-Töne generieren kann. Und dann klickert man sich da in seiner Kiste irgendwas hin, was zum Beispiel die MIDI-Töne für... generiert und die schickt man hier rein, in diesem Fall über ein USB-Kabel oder über ein MIDI-Kabel. Und das Interface generiert dann bei jedem... ein Rechteck für den beginnenden Ton und für den endenden Ton. Und in Abhängigkeit von der Tonhöhe, die es abzubilden hat, eine variable Steuerspannung, die ich eben in meine Oszillatoren schicke und damit die Tonhöhe umsetze.
Also so kann man dann auch die ganze digitale Welt und die ganze Möglichkeit an Zuspielung, da kann man ja dann auch über... es gibt ja MIDI, gibt es ja mittlerweile auch schon als Blasinstrumente etc., was auch alles noch verwenden, um die Klanganzugung zu machen. Was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, ist, jetzt haben wir hier diesen großen Koffer, man kann da so seine Kabel zusammen machen und das Ding hat ja auch in sich noch mal einen Mixer. Aber wie wird denn nun... benutzt man wirklich das Gerät so live auf der Bühne? Letzten Endes will man auch aus diesen Klängen dann irgendwie Musik machen. Das heißt, sehe ich das richtig, dass das eigentlich mehr nur so Klangbaustellen sind und wenn ich dann irgendwie das gefunden habe, was ich haben will, dann sample ich das und setze das dann so in meiner Sequencer-Software ein und mache dann irgendwie fertige Musik draus? Oder kommt das auch wirklich live zum Einsatz?
Das gibt es sicher auch, aber es kommt auch wirklich live zum Einsatz und das nicht nur bei Jean-Michel Jean, weil das, was wir hier jetzt zum Beispiel haben, das ist ja ein spielbarer Klang, den ich auch als geübter Musiker durchaus live einsetzen kann zu Gitarre, Bass, Schlagzeug oder einem Freund am Klavier. Und dafür, für diesen Klang, habe ich jetzt im Endeffekt nur vier oder fünf Module genötigt, irgendwas zu machen. Und dann kam schon der Mischer und ich könnte natürlich gleichzeitig jetzt ein wildes Geräusch empfinden oder zum Beispiel die Rhythmusmaschine in dem Filter den Rhythmus da zu spielen lassen, wo ich dann die Vögelgeräusche, die Grotoniumgeräusche wollte ich sagen, mir fehlten die Worte, noch dazu mische. Andere Geräusche, auch aus dem natürlichen Leben, kann man natürlich über ein Sampler-Modul dann in sein Modularsystem speichern. Das ist natürlich eine digitale Einheit, aber es gibt einen kleinen Streifen, das ist ein Sampler, da kann ich dann ein Sample reinschicken. Das kann ich vorher von zu Hause irgendwie oder aus einer Aufnahme irgendwie da drin zur Verfügung haben. Und in Abhängigkeit von einem Gate-Signal von meinem Sequencer wird das Sample abgespielt. Und in Abhängigkeit von einer Steuerspannung wird das Sample vorne beschnitten und fängt später an oder hinten beschnitten und hört früher auf. Und damit kann ich zum Beispiel mit drei Modulen oder so mir was machen, was das Wort Atomkraft in seinen einzelnen Scheibchen durchläuft und kann damit durchaus eine künstlerisch wertvolle Performance darstellen, die eben so zusammengeschlöpselt wurde, bespielbar ist. Da steckt ein Stecker rein und das geht los.
Das heißt, analog und digital widerspricht sich hier auch nicht. Wir reden ja im Prinzip auch gerade über zwei Sachen gleichzeitig. Wir haben auf der einen Seite so die analoge Klangerzeugung als solche, die sich dann ganz wunderbar zum Anfassen präsentiert, gerade mit so einem modularen System. Aber in so einem modularen System muss dann nicht zwingend alles analog sein, sondern da können auch genauso gut digitale Komponenten dazukommen, wie wir jetzt zum Beispiel gesehen haben mit diesem Effektprozessor, also das Heilgerät oder dieser Sampler, den du gerade meintest.
Genau, aber es hat natürlich eine andere Aura, so ein digitaler Hall, der verkörpert ja auch einen relevanten Einfluss auf diesen Klang. Und es gibt durchaus da auch ein mechanisches Effekt, eine Hallspirale fürs Modularsystem, was auch der Klassiker für das Trautonium gewesen wäre, den ein bisschen einen anderen Klang hat, wo ich eine kleine Hallspirale hinten in den Koffer reinklebe und vorne eine Steuereinheit habe oder die Hallspirale gar nicht reinklebe, sondern auf dem Tisch liegen habe, weil dann kann ich einfach in die Hallspirale reingreifen. Hätte ich auch noch mitbringen können, habe ich heute nicht. Kann ich gerne beim nächsten Mal vorzeigen oder hängt bei uns im Laden. Ansonsten habe ich natürlich auch jetzt ein paar Sachen mitgebracht, die wir gar nicht gebraucht haben, aber das macht ja gar nichts. Irgendetwas hat man immer dabei, was man nicht braucht. Da braucht jeder nur in seine eigenen Taschen greifen und denke mal...
Damit haben wir im Wesentlichen schon mal alles erklärt, wie das Ganze so funktioniert. Dieses Modulsystem, dieses Aufmaß, das hier alle reinpassen, das ist im Prinzip das, was mal der Herr Döpfner definiert hat und alle sind ihm gefolgt, oder?
Ja, genau. Das ist 3HE. Diese Module werden betrieben mit plus, minus 12 Volt, die auf der Rückseite auf einem Bus zur Verfügung stehen, die aber natürlich auch über ein freies Kabel irgendwie angeführt werden könnten. Aber das macht alles keinen richtigen Sinn, weil es passiert einem schon immer wieder, dass man in die Verlegenheit kommt und das eine Modul von unten rechts nach oben links haben will, weil man einfach das von unten rechts immer mit dem anderen Modul von oben links verwendet. Und bei seinem dritten Konzert oder bei der fünften Session merkt man, die kann ich auch gleich nebeneinander setzen. Dann habe ich da das kurze Kabel, dann habe ich es alles viel übersichtlicher. Und das geht mit diesem Dörfer-System ganz hervorragend. Ich habe mich jetzt auch mal in 5 HE-Systemen versucht, die der Klassiker unter dem Modularsystem sind, weil der Bob Moog seinerzeit sein erstes Modularsystem in 5 HE gebaut hat und dort mit 15 Volt so einen anderen Standard geschaffen hat, der sich in Amerika einer größeren Popularität erfreut. Und da geht das nicht so schnell, weil die ganzen Hersteller sich nicht auf eine Norm einigen konnten und jeder hat irgendwie hier ein bisschen anders, dann ist ein Modul ein bisschen breiter, dann ist der Hintergrund ein bisschen höher, dann benutzt der eine größere Schrauben, der andere kleinere Schrauben. Und da ist man eigentlich die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen am Improvisieren. Wenn man es sich leisten kann, eh alle Systeme zu haben und dann von dem einen, das da links stehen hat, von dem anderen das noch in der Mitte und von dem dritten, das noch rechts daneben, dann kann man die vorderseitig natürlich alle hervorragend miteinander verbinden, auch die Kleinen mit den Großen und dem sind dann überhaupt keine Grenzen mehr gesetzt. Aber das ist ja nicht die Realität dessen, der Musik machen will.
Ja, die Leute, die Musik machen wollen, die werden wahrscheinlich sowieso häufig dann erstmal auch zum Digitalmaterial greifen, sprich den Computer und Software einsetzen. Das ist ja sehr populär, weil da kommt man natürlich mit ganz anderen Platzbedarf im Zimmer. Daher und natürlich auch preislich, denke ich mal, dürfte das nochmal ein Unterschied sein.
Da möchte ich einmal kurz intervenieren, dass natürlich bei den digitalen Sachen davon ausgegangen wird, dass man einfach irgendwie den Computer auf dem Mutti, sonst auch die Haushaltsrezepte hat, womöglich auch noch Musik machen kann, weil man die Software ja frei runterladen kann und stößt dann ganz schnell an seine Grenzen, wenn man mal eine richtige Produktion machen will und dann wirklich mal drei Signale in guter Qualität gleichzeitig hören, aufnehmen und womöglich noch verändern möchte. Wo dann plötzlich irgendwelche Rechenzeiten oder was weiß ich. Gut, das wird alles immer besser, weißt du eh besser als ich. Aber trotzdem muss man für einen guten Musikcomputer auch erst mal drei Kilo aus der Hosentasche zaubern, um das zu haben, wo man dann überhaupt erst anfängt, über Musik nachzudenken.
Ja, ganz klar.
Und für die 3000 habe ich so eine Kiste schon voll. Wenn ich da ein bisschen sparsam rangehe, dann kriege ich für 3000 so einen Koffer, wie ich den hier mitgebracht habe, durchaus qualifiziert gefüllt. Und damit habe ich ein gutes Werkzeug, habe ich ein gutes Musikinstrument.
Und was vor allem eine ganz andere Haptik mit sich bringt. Dieses Gefummel mit Maus und so, das ist natürlich auch immer ganz schön elend. Das kann man sich natürlich dann wiederum auf entsprechende Midi-Controller legen und dann wieder den Schmerz wieder ein bisschen reduzieren, aber am Ende des Tages bleibt natürlich noch was anderes. Trotz alledem, wer jetzt über einfache Musiksoftware bereits verfügt und die sowieso da hat, bevor er sich jetzt mal gleich so ein Modul kauft, kann natürlich diese ganzen Prinzipien, über die wir jetzt hier gesprochen haben, auch zur Klangerzeugung nutzen und mal schauen, wie sich eigentlich Sound auf elektronischer Art und Weise zusammenbauen lässt. Also Oszillatoren erstmal an Start bringen, um Klänge überhaupt erstmal was zum Schwingen zu bringen, die dann wiederum in ihrer Art und Weise, wie sie oszillieren, beeinflussbar sind durch andere Module und mit verschiedenen Wellenformen, Hüllkurven etc. Filtern vor allem kann man dann im Prinzip unendliche Klangwelten erzeugen.
Es gibt die ganzen Komponenten und viele mehr natürlich in digitaler Form, einfach zum runterladen, wo man einfach per Ctrl-C, Ctrl-V sich drei Oszillatoren nebeneinander legen kann, die man untereinander verbinden kann, wo man auch durchaus mal so eine Cross-Modulation machen kann und gucken kann, was da passiert. Weil das ist natürlich im digitalen System logischerweise eine Höchstbelastung an Interaktionen, wenn zwei Oszillatoren sich gegenseitig befruchten. Ich habe in Luxemburg einen Workshop gemacht, wo ich Hardware vorgeführt habe und ein anderer, die passende Software von einer Firma Native Instruments, die das, was wir hier sehen, simuliert. Und er hat zu meinem großen Erstaunen erzählt, dass er, um einen klassischen Synthesizer wirklich anzulegen im Workshop, viel länger braucht, als ich mit meiner Hardware, wo ich einfach ein Kabel reinstecke, weil er die Module erst mal laden muss und nebeneinander konfigurieren und dann sagen muss, worauf sie hören müssen. Und das hat mich schon sehr erstaunt und enttäuscht. Wir werden versuchen, das dieses Jahr mal näher zusammenzubringen, dass ich auch von der Software von ihm was lerne und er von mir von der Hardware was lernt, und wir vielleicht parallel erklären, was eine Hölkurve ist. Das braucht man tatsächlich nur einmal lernen. Und hat es gecheckt, wenn man einmal ein Kabel reingesteckt hat und selber gecheckt hat, okay, ich stecke ein Kabel rein, da höre ich was, dann ziehe ich es wieder raus, dann ist es weg. Bei einer Maus ist es natürlich ein abstrakter, weil dann muss ich das Kabel am anderen Ende auch irgendwie reinstecken, und ich habe ja gar kein Kabel in der Hand. Also was soll die Animation, warum gibt es nicht einen Schalter, wo ich einfach an oder ausmache? Berechtigte Frage.
Ja, vielleicht zum Abschluss nochmal, wollte ich noch mal drauf kommen. Du hast ja schon gesagt, 70er-, 80er-Jahre, das war so die frühe Hochkultur der Synthesizer. Dann gab es 80er-, 90er-Jahre, ist alles ein bisschen überlagert worden zunächst von kompakteren digitalen Geräten, die alles in sich vereinigt haben. Ich denke, in den 90er-Jahren gab es dann auch einen großen Schub, nachdem jetzt im vergangenen Jahrzehnt hin das Ganze sozusagen in den Software zu machen. Jetzt beobachtest du so ein Wiederkehren des Bauens. Es gibt mehr Leute, die anfangen, wieder Synthesizer zu bauen. Was steckt da so kulturell dahinter? Warum ist das so?
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Individualität, nach der wir ja alle suchen, dass wir unseren eigenen Stempel irgendwo aufdrücken, dahin führt, dass eben das, was früher das Werkzeug auf der Bühne war, nämlich so eine Rhythmusmaschine von KORG und einen Synthesizer daneben, den man zusammen mit seinem Gitaristen und seinem Schlagzeuger performt hat, dass das eher zur Home-Entertainment-Elektronik wird und dass das Zeug, was wir hier machen, wo man sich individuell aus zehn Modulen sein Musikinstrument zusammenschraubt und das nochmal kombiniert mit drei anderen Geschichten eher das ist, was der Künstler auf der Bühne benutzt und dass der, die einzelne Komponente mehr und mehr zum selber definieren, die eigentlich kreative Prozess ist, das heißt, dass derjenige eben nicht mehr Musik auf Platten macht, sondern dass derjenige Musik mit Instrumenten macht, weil die Instrumente haben alle einen eigenen Klang. Der eine Oszillator klingt anders als der andere, der andere Filter klingt anders als der nächste und es gibt auch Module, die kombinieren drei Sachen, die haben zwei Zufallsspannungen und zwei eigene Oszillatoren drin, wo die ganze Zeit, die man auf der Bühne hat, irgendein Gebrezel rauskommt, wo du denkst, aha, okay, aber das verstehe dann selbst ich nicht mehr, wo ich davor stehe und denke, ist ja toll, aber das führt meinen, ich kann auf alles Einfluss nehmen, wieder total ad absurdum. Da steckst du ein Kabel rein und dann kommst du, und dann kannst du verschiedene Komponenten von Zufällen beeinflussen. Das ist sehr innovativ und bringt dich auf total neue Gedanken. Wenn du auf sowas stehst, hat eine eigene Dimension und da gibt es immer mehr Leute unten, die das neu erfinden, die da irgendwie neue Sachen entwickeln und der Löter wird, glaube ich, an sich so langsam zum Künstler. Das Problem ist, dass man das alles gar nicht mehr so richtig öffentlich abbilden kann, was fast auf die komplette Mannschaft meiner Lieferanten zutrifft. Das findet ja alles keine große Öffentlichkeit. Ich bin so ein bisschen das Indie-Label oder eins von den Indie-Labels, die da irgendwie so von 0 bis 100 kommt, was man tatsächlich in Stückzahlen so umsetzen kann und darüber hinaus geht es entweder gar nicht oder geht irgendwie einmal im Jahr für einen der Hersteller manchmal, die dann, wie man das früher sagen würde, einen Major-Deal haben.
Die dann mehr verkaufen, weil sie dann viel verkaufen.
Genau, aber die meisten sind in ihren Studios und basteln ihr eigenes Zeug. Und das ist dann entweder das Circuit-Bending, wo es experimentell zu Gange geht, oder halt Ingenieurswissen, was dann mal für die eigene Kunst angewendet wird, in Abwendung der sonst einem Ingenieur anheimlich beruflichen Pflichten bei Siemens oder was weiß ich. Ich würde gerne noch dazu sagen, ich wundere mich, wer sich das jetzt alles anhört, was ich da erzählt habe.
Da wundere ich mich auch immer drüber.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt, möchte mich gerne höflich dafür entschuldigen, wenn es ein bisschen lang an mich war, aber das war ein sehr schönes Gespräch und das hat hier Spaß gemacht. Wir haben davor gestanden und haben hier einen großen Spaß gehabt.
Bisschen rumgejammt.
Ja, schon. Also war jetzt nicht viel Musik, war eher so theoretisches Parlava.
Naja, wir wollten ja auch nicht Musik machen, sondern es ging ja hier um Synthesizer und mir ging es auch wirklich mehr darum, zu verstehen, wie man eigentlich so einen Klang aufbaut, dass wir jetzt hier nicht unbedingt den Megasound der nächsten zehn Jahre gefunden haben. Das mag der kurzen Testzeit hier geschuldet sein. Aber auf jeden Fall, so machen das Leute. Es gibt Klangerzeuger, die stellen sich vor diese Geräte und finden dort irgendwie einen Klang oder auch einen Klangverlauf, der einfach ihrer Musik dann so ein i-Tüpfelchen aufsetzt oder vielleicht auch überhaupt erst mal das i einfügt, damit das alles sich vorwärts bewegt.
Ich kann nur jedem empfehlen... Das sind auch so totale Klang-Nerds, oder? Ja, wie gesagt, es sind teilweise sehr anzunehmende Musikanten der Neuzeit und Gegenwart, teilweise erfolgreiche Künstler, die viele Platten verkaufen, teilweise auch wirklich einfach experimentelle Kellermusik-Bastler, die einen großen Spaß daran haben, für sich selber was zu machen. Und das hat alles seine Berechtigung und macht mit Sicherheit alles Spaß. Ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, das zumindest mal auszuprobieren und im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeiten, sich vielleicht was zu leihen oder bei einem Freund einfach mal eine Hand anzulegen und rauszufinden, ob das was für einen ist, indem man da ein bisschen... Das kriegt man nicht mehr eben in einem Nachmittag raus und da muss man sich auch nicht... Ich meine, man kann sich das nicht runterladen. Man muss eben irgendwo Hand anlegen. Das heißt, es braucht eigentlich Läden und es braucht eigentlich einen Ort der Begegnung.
Ja, diesen Ort der Begegnung gibt es ja auch, nämlich dein Laden, Schneiders Laden. Das ist in Berlin, um Kurt Busattor. Da kann man auch auftrauen und da kann man sich dann auch mal diese ganzen modularen Synthesizer und Theréminer und was ja nicht sonst noch alles rumsteht auch mal anschauen. Wer sich da inspirieren lassen will, sicherlich herzlich eingeladen. Ja, muss ich sagen, machen wir jetzt mal den Deckel drauf hier auf die Apparatur, packen wir uns den Kabel wieder ein und ich bedanke mich für deine Ausführung, Andreas.
Und ich bedanke mich für die Einladung.
Und dann bedanke ich mich auch gleich nochmal, und zwar wie immer bei den Zuhörern hier bei Chaosradio Express und hier geht es auch bald wieder weiter. Ihr wisst ja, mit viel Spaß am Gerät, mal mit Klang und mal ohne Klang, aber auf jeden Fall immer mit Informationen, wie es weitergehen soll.